hello hello everybody
Wednesday a glorious beautiful day
happens to be February 15th
nice uh sharp winter day outside a
little Breezy a little Sunny you know
what it is
quarter past one o'clock today folks
thanks for tuning in to Adrian bogas
today we've got an excellent Jody for
you brought to you by honey
Ed stamps.com
Give It Up
give it up for him who we love so well
yeah right
[Music]
I'm just gonna fart
Ed
I'm such a sucker
why does I care about that why is it a
character
it's so stupid
that is the dumbest [__] about this show
and by the way if you have not seen this
show a lot that is just the most
nonsensical crap you could ever wait to
see we were we were trying something
different this week no I liked it don't
get me wrong I like the whole carrot
Vibes you know yeah we were uh they
pitched me something like they're like
Zach makes something kind of like
atonally and I'm I guess that would work
out but a little simpler I guess would
be the turn yeah it's stripped down a
little more uh percussion heavy yeah I
really yeah I dug that yeah I like that
well there It Is Well thank you guys
it's off the rails of course
uh today's episode we're gonna get very
weird and very off the rails Oh weird
actually not looking forward to it at
all
gonna be awful
um Sam once again is here to torture us
with disgusting crap
when did you make this Sam we drank beer
they're fresh I made them this morning
oh my God okay it's fresh I like that
oh yeah yeah yeah so we are playing
cursed beer pong
like beer Senator and instead of beer of
course it is the most disgusting vile
potions known to man created by Sam
and her witch hut
in a cauldron the frog legs this is
[__] gross how much of this [__] are
we supposed to drink
I guess I don't know I've played beer
pong like once it's like a shot it would
be like a shot it's just the zip well in
beer pong it's like a significant amount
of beer you drink but not in cursed beer
pots just enough to leave you wanting
more right this one is called Klein wine
can't wait to see what's been floating
in there
another kind of milk oh so this is just
semen I'm assuming
yes
ninjas goo thank God for that oh finally
we've got milk nectar this has alcohol
in it
can only hope that's the milk part I'm
assuming because they're all alcoholics
I'm done there's a happy Dad oh happy
Dad happy Dad yeah
this one's for you Olivia yak and Coke
exactly it's star Yak jerky oh oh that
is for me wait we got star Yak jerky
yeah we have it what what the hell you
holding on on me for I've been wanting
to try that for ages do you want me to
bring it out yeah bring it out because
we wanted to do that in our influencer
tier list I guess we finally got it
World bath tonic
that was one dirty gamer girl
that is some murky [__] up bathwater
Club Primal punch
you can't see it but this is a spitting
[__] image of my pesto [__] yeah can
you kill the green screen for a sec the
key
you guys got to see this this is this is
exactly what my [__] looked like yeah
disgusting yeah you should have called
this Ethan's pesto pillow see I'm a
missed opportunity because that would
have made it way worse
yes we got Yak jerky
he's slaughtering a lot of yaks
you know
uh-huh he must like killing Yaks because
there's no way he's making any
measurable amount of money from this he
just gets off on killing the yaksi
lovingly raised off
Swedish meatball
Mark Martini ew that sounds good dude I
don't know how we're gonna make it
through this Sam this is so epic are all
these uh do any of them have like meat
in it this one has meat it's labeled
there's there's two that have me and
there's one that has alcohol none of
them have pork
I've got it Jimmy Lee's Jersey iced tea
this has meat in it ew dude why all
different flavors
the stuff that gave kavcav an alleged
DUI oh this is what he was drinking on
that fateful night allegedly nice
drive angry dude this is gonna be hard I
think this is gonna be our the hardest
nastiest challenge we've done
we'll see we shall see great
very cool let's just put that aside for
now
yeah so we're going to be competing to
see
who's gonna Yak the fastest in front of
Olivia
how long has this been open Sam
just this morning okay cool so this is
star yak yak jerky
and and uh what what did this cost us
I think for the receipt right now I'll
let you know oh we got Yak sticks
everybody
that I was craving that
the sticks of the yak thank you Bella
Simmons for 50 gifted that's so gracious
what do we know about this Yak Farm
actually like how many Yaks are there
what is going on at that yak Farm do we
have any intel Gooch Family Farms
the bag of sticks was 15 and the
jalapeno jerky was 12.
fifteen dollars for like four eight
ninety nine shipping
[Music]
that's what I mean he's not selling a
lot of this [__] he just likes killing
his yaks
is is it definitely not like just
rebranded garbage cheap
uh wait Ricky
white label yeah could be I feel like
that would make more sense that would be
insane I mean here it says
goals here it says process for Star Yak
rant four it's totally a white label
thing oh yeah look at that process for
you well no he's if he sends the yak
meat
to uh right because he doesn't have like
chefs I'm assuming I'm the meat shop
because it doesn't correct what it
doesn't make any [__] sense for him
to do this this business model makes
zero sense but if it's a white label it
I guess it makes more sense but it's
still weird but I think that's like well
that's like straight up false advertise
yeah
That's a classic though I mean the
first ingredient is yak
where's he getting where's the importing
Yak meat from then
you need a yak I can get you a yak he
has a yak form okay but we have to
import it
you're saying it's a well yeah I'm just
speculating I mean just based off of
that wording
what what part of Economics don't make
sense to you like either he has a yak
Farm big enough that he's able to ex
make a bunch of jerky out of it or he's
just buying Yak meat from somewhere else
animal processing center like to be
profitable in a business like this
you need like
I think a pretty significant meat
processing center and I thought he just
had like a few Yaks for fun I didn't
know he was had like a whole you'd just
be partnered with one I'm sure there's
plenty in Wyoming
slaughterhouse he says he said at one
point he had a hundred yaks
separate from the ones he's killing yeah
so he has yeah his his 100 he acts out
the wazoo
Yakety Yak don't talk back what is that
from
from that old
silly song I don't even know this looks
disgusting oh brother this looks bad
oh it don't smell good either
[Applause]
it tastes like beef jerky
like that's gonna make me sick someone
get me a tissue
I need somebody in the chat has uh I
don't this is I don't know if this is a
speculation or whatever but they said he
does it to get the agricultural
exemption on the taxes for his land oh I
don't I don't think those are tissues
yeah
those sticks are [__] up the beef
church is fine because like it's super
dry
but these ones are a little juice
it tastes like beef jerky and that is
[__] me up like why is there all this
goo all over maybe you want to try this
you're the you're a jerky expert all
right I'm okay oh my God I I don't know
if that's hello I've never heard of yeah
I have no idea can we search for it
because I don't want to give you an out
the Halal out
um
carrot says Yak is the Most Blessed meat
under Allah
I just found that on the internet
a law says specifically yakumi is
awesome kill all the acts he hated yeah
he hated Yaks eat them all I'm saying uh
the Quran says not if it's from Jeffree
Star okay that makes sense yeah fair
enough very Traditional Values yeah
well that's disgusting and very
expensive
but now I'm actually here I want to know
the real story of this Yak meat
so I'm gonna do some research on his
website and see if you can dig into any
of the details of this I don't know I'm
I don't know why you're so baffled by it
well either he's importing yakme which
is like false advertising straight up
yeah or I would lean towards that being
or he's not selling he's taking a loss
and just killing these Yaks because he's
a [__] monster well you were spitting
out um your food and gagging when I said
it but somebody in the chat said that um
he's just doing it to get a tax
exemption in Wyoming for having a farm
what tax exemption is Wyoming what the
[__] what you know I mean like
I think they pay you to live there yeah
yeah I don't know if yeah if you have a
farm out here
that we don't charge you no tax oh God
get off
please
in fact
if you got a farm out here we just give
you
a hundred thousand acres of land there's
so much land out here in Dayton nobody
live here I have a question did you work
on your Midwestern accent at all dude
the midwestern accent is not
what it's not pronounced enough like
pronounced enough I don't it's a subtle
accent I agree I agree with that because
everybody says I have one and
you know I can't tell or anything it's
it's not your little impersonation of
all you don't do it all [__]
Minnesota [__] my Chicago family yes
that's not a Midwestern accent you're
talking like someone from from Winnipeg
it's from Chicago no it's not nobody in
Chicago talks like that do you want a
bet do you wanna [__] bet on that
sure okay find me a [__] from
Chicago city that talks like that okay
you're talking with like a Minnesota
accent stop the madness that's not
Chicago
Chicago you called it a Midwest accent
Midwest that is the Midwest yeah who in
here is from the Midwest raise your hand
Amy have you ever ran into somebody
that talks like Zach is doing right now
in Chicago I have thank you thank you
baby but it's not common it's it's not
common it's a deep Chicago accent I mean
you're really playing it up it's like
how I don't think it's like a Boston
accent it's like not everybody okay you
said Midwest accent a b u and Leonard
are both from the Midwest go ahead and
say hi this is my accent
well hi there this is my accent sounds
just like me you see yeah Lena I love
you but you have a little of that
Midwest it's it's fine everybody tells
me that I just don't hear it it's very
subtle it's not something I could even
impersonate Zach
we've never heard anyone back home speak
the way you Zach is thank you Lena
somebody who understands me a b you're
demoted
my favorite
very odd has just been uh how could I
pick a favorite between you two great
people
down here and down here in Chicago
right there you go you have it that's
right Ethan is right it's Minnesota
thank you chatters
Zach is wrong thank you
I see you're skipping a lot of messages
I'm I'm reading what's in front of me
dude my grandmother was from one
Wisconsin and Chicago okay I think she
just
she she has the thickest like accent in
in Ethan's defense I think most of
Zach's impersonations based off SNL
sketch from like the 90s you talking
about Dick yeah the Bears
that's the ultimate insult by the way
foreign
by the way this person uh fight off your
DM's demon says I'm from Chicago I'm in
Chicago I lived out of the state for
five years Michigan sorry [__] I'm from
Michigan I lived out of the state for
five years and the accents are very
prominent Lena has a heavy Michigan
accent which means that your point is
[__] how how am I supposed to in
person sound like Lena talk like Lena
Zach
Lena give me just like a little bit of
like banter what do you want me to say
what do you want Chicago you know you're
doing the same noise
I'm switching sides thank you this is
just you know what I mean here I can't
take listen I've perfected my American
accent
and I will not be slandered by you okay
I feel like you have a Californian
accent Zach California next like your
Cadence is is a lot
well yeah I didn't grow up in the
midwest yeah I'm from here yeah I know
I'm just saying I hear an accent with
you too
you know what I mean you sound like a
character we don't have accents in
California we literally is like what
English language what are you talking
about right now we talk oh it's like
this literally what are you like
literally what are you doing yeah it's
kind of dragged out a little bit yeah
what are you talking what are you even
talking what are you talking about right
now sounds [__] crazy yeah I did why
are you roasting Stevo what do you do
because I love Stevo
by the way I went to the dermatologist
yesterday
and uh
I finally got a cream for my [__] up
face
it looks worse than ever I put it on
last night and the camera's nice and
close today so you can see
but I'm gonna put it on every day for
two weeks every night
it's an oil oh I'm being told this is
actual that's his actual face I'm so
sorry Ethan
oh roasted at the streamies
[__]
also they removed I had like a wart or a
mole or something here my whole life
part of the geography of my face that's
yeah and I says I wish he was doing a
mole inspection on me and he looked at
this one and he says let's take it out
Wild
so
um
it was actually really easy surprisingly
I haven't been to the dermatologist in a
while but they he gave it a little shot
to numb it um
which didn't really hurt that much
I did yeah a few of them and they sliced
it right off
damn that's it that's part of your look
yeah I know but I guess it was if there
was a chance it might kill me or
something
I'm glad you got it taken care of I'll
be honest I'm kind of glad it's gone
just because it always itchy and there's
like weird hairs that grow out of it
it's disgusting I have to like pluck the
hairs out and it hurts it's very
sensitive
so that's gone
Good Vibes also Zach my mama is from
Chicago by the way she was born and
lived there till the age of 10. okay
have you heard my mom talk yeah we'll
move to California so I feel like that
the chick goes away okay
I just want to say I'm from the South
Ethan and I don't sound like your
southern accent
well of course not you're from
where you're from North Carolina right
Georgia who are you again by the way
Georgia
they all that whole area kind of mixed
together
well yeah Georgia I mean yeah not
everybody sounds like that
but I bet you met someone talk like this
down there boy you know what I mean
that's a it's a very south Georgia thing
that's right we down here in South
Georgia ain't no City Slickers we don't
talk like them fancy city Folk
sometimes when I talk to Sam by the end
of the conversation I'll have like a
little bit of a twang on accident little
twang it just sounds great that's right
I think I have an accent though you you
totally yeah it's got to be subtle it's
enough that like I love it and I wish I
had it no no it's very subtle sometimes
you turn it on and that's cool like you
did the other day oh oh yeah yeah well I
was I was playing it up a little bit
yeah I feel like it come it comes out
sometimes okay Zach do an impression of
Sam's accent
talk for me a little you're gonna do the
Chicago one aren't you what do you want
me to say what do you want me to will
you hold on and that's not what I said
you literally go down twang you know for
a while she doesn't sound like that you
declare my name is
a car Named Desire Zach my name is Sam I
do I do I do the Vipers for a while you
know go down and get some beef jerky you
know get some Sam Sam Tampa spot on
subtle Zach you can't do it look just
just embrace it people from Chicago talk
like this
yo love what state are you from you got
a funny accent love what state are you
from dude yeah dude Arizona
Gators
yes so uh we got a lot to get to today I
could talk about this all day
in fact I nearly have already it's
probably been 30 minutes of this [__] uh
just 20. yeah so
one thing I want to get to at the top of
the show before it makes me sick and I
think this happens every time we got the
McDonald's has a new meal and you know
I'm a sucker for this [__]
just gives me a reason to eat McDonald's
because let's be real it's just normal
food made in a way that you don't really
like I'm such a sucker it's like the
opposite of have it your way yeah I
would like have it their way yeah well I
don't want it their way
well we were talking about it before the
show and I I just feel like they've
really been lowering the bar because
when they kick this all I don't was the
BTS one the first one no well it was
certainly the muddy hottie it was
certainly no it was the Cactus Jack one
the muddy hoodie wasn't even a
McDonald's I know wait but I think they
trailblazed this whole concept maybe
that was first I don't know but nobody
taught BTS they had the special sauce
made just for them hold on show me and
it was actually pretty good so of course
it was good though never misses
the implication that BTS would have even
missed that I find offensive thank you
Sam
highly offensive shame on you
two drinks they come that size yeah you
have to drink them both what the [__]
why would I want to oh is this a meal
for a couple
it's the night before Thanksgiving right
it's the biggest trick in the year
[Music]
Travis Scott was first says the chat I
think that's right Travis Scott was the
finally McDonald's has a meal for two
AKA a meal for me one
I like the I like the guardian
an offset Meal please for one
it's just me
uh look at the size of these drinks what
[__] psycho is gonna take these to
the Dome it's me
I'm half of America bro this doesn't
even diet right this is like one or well
let's let's say what the meal is all
right let's read it off
so here's cardi B and offset
I didn't even know there was a demand
for this [__] I don't know how they
figuring this stuff out
so the meal is
this what is this
ready ready
see his order is a 20. nugget he likes a
quarter pounder wait hold the [__]
phone
it's for Valentine's Day
that's a weird intro but you know cardi
B she probably slips some uh it's like a
hamburger with G what's the GHB yeah
it's a hamburger GHP sprinkled on for
that would be the real cardi B hamburger
didn't she admit to doing that and
stealing people's money
yeah I don't know if it was GHB but she
used to hustle people
um
also Travis Scott was the second meal
the first meal was Michael Jordan
go dude his meal his meal uh
quarter pounder with American cheese
bacon oh American cheese America yep
circular bacon designed to fit perfectly
over the burger patty mustard pickles
onions and a new barbecue sauce created
exclusively for the burger so see he
that's fire exclusive barbecue sauce
different shaped bacon that's like a
custom Meal special so read this off
because I when I read this I couldn't
believe it let me watch this video
so so yeah we we do a special drink um
coke with a little bit of um
formaldehyde in it
gives it a nice taste makes you pass out
take all your [__]
oh how about this one of the drinks you
don't know which one
comes with um
what was that old-timey drug that
Quaalude
one of them has Quaalude mixed in so the
other one passes out and then you can
steal their ketchup packets all
different flavors you can steal their
barbecue one because they're passed out
don't drive and eat this meal cook folks
thank you I don't know Kenny's order
then I don't know Kenny oh ready you
ready
see his order is a 20 piece Chicken
McNugget what a beast 20 pieces bro you
know each other's McDonald order
that's true love
who me and Lena you guys yeah we do what
is it what's hers Lena gets a fish
fillet sandwich and a meal with a Coke
do you eat fish fillet
a Double Quarter Pounder that's right
yeah okay is that controversial that you
eat the fish fillet
no because she she grew up in Dearborn
where that's pretty much the only thing
they could eat on the menu because it's
the only things hello we used to do um
Halal um chickens but then it turned out
that they weren't actually Halal and
everyone found out until they they got
rid of it and stuff oh no yeah it was
hard that must have been traumatic it
was it really was
yo what the [__] cardi B's got straws on
her fingers
looks like you could dunk those right in
the drink and
sip them through her hands like a anime
[__]
person yeah
like so quarter pound butter you like
french fries and milkshakes yes I do is
just cheese sweet tea because you're a
Midwestern boy true I get boyfriend
points with like I get the last fry I
agree no
let's be real these people would not be
alive if they ate McDonald's regularly
it's a conspiracy
this bro oh my good old wine Fair gets
her a Big Mac every day
yeah right she'd be dead 15 years ago
they're actually 14. and I can't
this is what you look like on Big Mac
any questions
you don't yes you do who steals more
fries it's Gotta Be You are we getting
[__] special I'm not watching this
[__] anymore they're using the same uh
song I used in the end of the year edit
oh for real yeah who's that as well
McDonald's used a royalty-free some well
it's it's a famous opera song so I don't
know if that okay
so where's the here let me pull up the
menu I'm not watching that propaganda
absolute propaganda
all right here it is
now how much was this meal
well I've got the meal I know what it
looks like I got it on Postmates and it
was 18.99 on Postmates
out the door or that not with delivery
not with delivery just okay that seems
fair
the meal is a cheeseburger with BBQ
sauce and a large Coke that's cardi B's
wow that is the most [__] basic ass
McDonald's order well not the most
because they did sub the barbecue sauce
but yeah it's not cheeseburger with BBQ
sauce and large Coke crazy
and then
um a quarter pounder with cheese and a
large High sea orange lava burst
epic right
I never heard of that I see orange lava
burst
that's just the high sea that that they
always have at McDonald's right like the
orange orange yeah the chick's coated
dude
hmm
so when they when they pour in the
crushed up Tylenol PMs that on the menu
or do they are you supposed to do that
yourself
is that an old-timey joke Zach is that
why you're doing it yes
come on that's funnier than Jimmy Lee
would have of course it is
so there it is so let's try it
um let's the fries tastes like let's try
it the quarter pounder with cheese
everyone did you guys have any to try
no
you guys know what McDonald's french
fries taste like
those are good
give it a shot all right oh my God this
thing is hard as a rock
this is not that old to be this stale
what on Earth is this thing
[Music]
looks great dude is that a hamburger
that is the saddest looking thing who
made this Mr Beast
it's a romantic Valentine's Day meal
right there dude so tiny all right so
this is uh
wait this doesn't have cat it's just
supposed to have barbecue sauce it's
just ketchup it's just a normal
hamburger
I think the barbecue sauce is on the
side right oh what they're gonna put it
on
oh there's a hamburger this is a
cheeseburger it tastes like beef jerky
so it's just a standard cheeseburger
I'll take it back it is the most basic
thing you could probably give you a
barbecue sauce on the side cool
that'll be twenty dollars this is the
craziest marketing scheme ever that's
what I meant by they're just dropping
the ball like early the MJ one and the
BTS one they put some effort into that
but well here let me do it her way [__]
let me put it do it her way
hey I don't want it my way
I want it her way
Tangy BBQ sauce baby
this is gonna
blow my [__] tits right off my body
oh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
tastes like a hammer with barbecue sauce
on it this has got to be the worst one
yet
right
just like hands down I mean
you know what's funny is they probably
charge you for the BBQ sauce too
it's probably like 25 cents probably to
get that on the side
I think doing a cardi B offset meal was
a super good idea for McDonald's but
they did choose very boring things
like they could have made it a little
extra special do you think this is
genuinely their order did they get in a
lab and like figure this out like well
I'm gonna find no I'm inclined to
believe it is
I'm not too stupid yeah that's why it's
so boring this is just like they did
this thing and they asked them what
their favorite meal is and I don't know
Quarter Pounder so this is just a normal
quarter pounder with cheese
it's pretty dumb
American McDonald's menu is so boring in
Sweden we get like super interesting
stuff
it's weird
what you got
in Sweden
uh we got like Max selection Royal
Deluxe premium beef crafted chicken
black garlic hot jalapeno there's a
bunch of fun things chicken tasty they
have [__] jalapenos a McDonald's in
Sweden I think America but nobody wants
it
we never get the the yeah we never get
any any [__] like that like the the
weird marketing things we just get good
stuff you guys have chicken in the bone
there too don't you yeah we have chicken
wings hot wings yeah it's a weird thing
in Sweden where all hamburger places has
uh shaken wings and hot wings it's kind
of kind of cool is it caterpillar there
yeah everyone it's like a side order
it's just like it's like pretty cheap
it's like two bucks for four or five
Wings it's quite nice it's quite nice
you sure you want to come here dude with
all that dude that sounds like Utopia
bro dude I sent you the the the menu if
you want to see all right well here I'm
gonna try the coke
this is of course uh cardi B's style so
let me try this coke let me see what
this tastes like
hmm
wow
nice
it tastes like beef jerky other than
here actually it's something I've never
tried
you've never had the high sea Orange
from McDonald's lava burst I never even
heard of the damn thing
here I'm trying it this is offsets
it's almost like we're friends in this
moment
tastes like orange slice
right
uh-huh
and
who the [__] would order this people
aren't actually ordering this right I
hope not because
previously didn't we drive through and
they were like confused when we asked
for it like
Travis Scott oh
Jasmine
28-month member just commented I'm an
assistant manager at McDonald's and this
meal is an embarrassment
it's been out for two days and I've
worked two full nine hour shifts and no
one has ordered it
that's actually comforting to me
because thanks for that for that Intel
it's nice to know
that people aren't this [__] dumb
we're the first people to buy this [__]
it doesn't even have a custom bag
previously they had like a custom bag or
something
um
wait the bag wasn't even customer
no
right Sam this is a normal ass
McDonald's bag
is that right yeah I don't think it came
in like the the special packaging didn't
Ian
that no everything is normal here
it's just straight up McDonald's oh I
forgot about this guys
this is special right they don't usually
have an apple pie
they've had an apple pie for about 50
years
it's good if you haven't tried it you're
missing out you never had their apple
pie it's pretty decent actually
you're telling me that
this is all just
the real goated one is the holiday pie
that they make I love that here's me by
myself sadly eating the cardi B meal on
Valentine's Day by myself lonely as [__]
eating someone else's McDonald's meal
Garden it up
[Laughter]
you went through the McDonald's
drive-through and then parked at Denny's
and brought it in to eat alone this is
so good it looks so real
and you brought your own gamer Subs too
here wait let me look like a real person
just Superstar
very pedestrian very beautiful
it's kind of kind of relaxing with just
the music but everybody be quiet for a
second
[Music]
okay
Railway Surfer who
number 26.
[Applause]
this is core core
32.
foreign
okay close up
this is the uh reality where you never
met Ela
it needs that annoying beep
beep what's this play we're putting on
it works well with the uh
with this shirt
beep beep beep
[Music]
how'd I do that was great good
nailed it right
it's almost like I am that guy yep just
being myself
that was nice that was disappointing
this way you can get in Sweden
yeah I did there's a lot of goods I'll
be honest
say jalapeno yellow piano cheese and
Fries guys doesn't look that good it
looks kind of good though she's gonna be
something I don't even like you know
it's going to be soggy
I don't like cheese honestly
yeah but I I just said it looks good
because it's from Sweden I bet it would
be good
also what does it really look like
because I ain't never seen cheese hang
like this
like I don't know about this one but I
will I will stand up for the noodles
they look real good
the what yes the hamburger oh I remember
they look really good comparing
comparison to the American ones I had
find me a picture
um
I want the I want to know what the
Swedish Prince eats at um McDonald's
you talking about cool stuff
shout out to Carla good stuff shout out
to Carl Gustav everybody call calling
Gustav Philippines
wait there's a whole bunch of meals on
here where are we getting the Carl
Gustav meal wait what the [__]
are they serious right now that looks
interesting okay well at least it's
different but it's [__]
is this a joke
how do they wrap that up well how are
you supposed to eat this that's a good
question Olivia
if the sauce is on top yeah why are they
putting sauce on top that's just
nonsense I think it's like an open face
uh peanut butter and jelly sandwich you
know it's very delicately
that's hard they have to put it in the
in the cardboard that's how they do it
yeah they're capping they're McDonald's
okay so that's
saw Wheaties
Mariah Carey what the [__] is this
this isn't real [__] is it
I I think some of them were just like
seasonal menu things but the other ones
were legit I mean there's Cactus Jack
was on there BTS now the cardi B one all
right let's start over and let's see
the cactus yes so this is Michael Jordan
yep
Cactus Jack this is when it all went
downhill let's be real
beginning of the end this is like you
can draw a straight line from this to
all those people dying it okay I see the
custom bag with this one mm-hmm
I think they were confused because he
said ask for Jack and then Ian's like
yeah Jack sent me and they didn't know
what the hell he was talking about I
mean they should know you can infer yeah
it's not that big a leap
six dollars straight up
a little races
you know what I mean
who's this
who's jabe okay so I'd say that's
probably the time he comes up on the
show
you you exclaim who the [__] is this I'd
say that's the most goaded combination
why does this man have his own eye even
though the [__] he is we have talked
about him so many times he he had a
whole thing with Logan Paul he's Puerto
Rican and was calling out Logan Paul
it wasn't that
oh bad but I'm not gonna get confused
are you really about to lecture me on
Tuesday j balvin's a Colombian rapper
okay uh he has come up on the show
before though well apparently using that
story but
okay he's Puerto Rican he's not my demo
close it up BTS obviously crushed
crushed look at these handsome man
these little ones worthy let's be let's
be real I wish every celebrity one would
just be another reissue of BTS
yeah the sales would be higher
the world needs that right now too
because aren't they in the Army now oh
[__] is the BTS on on hold right now
yeah yeah there oh God BTS is
I don't want to say no more so maybe
their meal should come with like bullets
no we need to forget about all that we
need to forget about the military yes
maybe they're
maybe they're um meals should come with
an inflatable balloon with the help sign
in it that says gives coordinates to
North Koreans of how to escape safely
yeah we should do that I like that
definitely we should do that the oldest
member of BTS has recently completed his
training
oh he's out yeah no no no it's training
yeah
send him to the front I'm sure he's
going right to the the demilitarized
zone exactly
mm-hmm he's too pretty to see action
you know what I mean
this is crazy this is just some
silliness
what did Mariah Carey get
the Mariah menu consisted of 12 days
worth of McDonald's classics
12 days worth wait am I wait are you
serious this is a big old bag of freeze
it and you eat one every day
[Music]
that might be the saddest meal
the Mary menu consisted of 12 days worth
of McDonald's class Each of which the
singer claims to love ordering the Big
Mac the McChicken the McDouble
McDonald's cinnamon roll
et cetera Etc so you get all that you
know so each day one of those items
would be released for free
what yeah
for free they begin wait what she's a
queen dude
give them back to the people
where does it say that
here I'll send you the link holy [__]
dude that would be a frenzy
that's kind of dope see now that's dope
but cam figured it out by the way it was
with Brittany we had a whole
conversation about oh okay I didn't
connect the dots
so she's a fan of course oh yeah yeah I
mean there's not many people she doesn't
like
to her you know credit
she's like the opposite of me in that
sense
free menu items every day leading up to
Christmas
dude that is actually
the coolest thing ever well the devil's
in the details if you scroll down this
is the first 10 000 people but I don't
know what the radius is of that like is
it per store per store or yeah 10 000
per store that's insane for one store
it's one day yeah but how do they how do
they regulate that
cross country
no it says the first ten thousand people
to get the deal will get a free beanie
oh oh
okay yeah she's still the queen of Chris
it's a big difference Abe yeah I know
I'm I'm reading this on the Fly
and you're almost there percent
difference is astronomical
well shout out to Mariah Carey my God
out Mariah All I Want For Christmas
is a sausage biscuit
thank you all right well there you go
no
kill it
uh we're at uh we're at break time we
had the acne we had uh McDonald's
I'm feeling pretty good over here
fantastic
all right let's thank our sponsors and
then
we've got a whole bunch of other fun
stuff to get to before beer pong
this is the H3 podcast forever
okay now I do the ads right
[Music]
boom
okay nice
this one's brought to you by the sexy
the voluptuous
the always tender loving honey baby
today's episode is sponsored by Honey
the easy way to save When shopping on
your iPhone or computer
[Music]
I love honey this is one of these
products that is just
so easy and so useful
completely free that if you're not using
it you're doing yourself a disservice
you don't even have to think about it
dude
these are
I love how we monetize that man
you think Crowder knows we use that
during our ad reads
hope he does hope so it's awesome
[Music]
yeah these are all legit savings from us
here in the
in the office
here's how it works
they've eliminated the need for
searching for coupon codes
it's a free shopping tool that scours
the internet for promo codes and applies
the best when it finds to your cart
imagine you're shopping at one of your
favorite sites
when the checkout comes the honey button
appears
and all you have to do is Boop like this
[Music]
apply coupon
wait a few seconds as honey searches for
coupons you can find for that site and
Bob is your uncle
if it finds a coupon the price drops a
magically and immediately
I swear to God it's like ninety percent
of the time these days I'm buying
something online Honey comes in for the
discount
[Music]
you guys find that to be true it's it's
kind of surprising how
we say I have 90 success but it it pops
up quite often like what what if you
expect I mentioned the other day but
just uh this week or last week I ordered
uh Valentine's Day stuff from uh
from one of those places that you were
Valentine's Day stuff from and yeah it's
uh it popped up with the coupon for I
saved like 35 bucks or something and you
were not gonna ever gonna go find it I
mean I was ready to pay full price yeah
never would have thought about it but
there it was it's incredible so awesome
um also here's something cool it doesn't
just work on the desktop anymore it also
works on your iPhone just activate it on
Safari on your phone and save on the go
so if you don't already have honey
you're gonna be straight up missing out
and by getting it you'll be doing
yourself a solid and supporting this
show
thank you for that by the way so get
PayPal honey for free
at joinhoney.com H3 that's
joinhoney.com H3 we love you honey
love honey mm-hmm
everything tastes better
with honey
[Music]
so true that can't be true actually
there's got to be everything
especially Pizza
yeah it can't be true
I also want to give a huge thank you to
the one the only
[Music]
stamps.com
I love stamps.com
this is one of the greatest sponsors of
ours because it's such a legit company
they're so well established and the
product they offer is absolutely awesome
the years go by if you're a small
business owner or just someone who's
side hustling
You're Gonna Want to save as much time
as possible and that's where stamps.com
comes in
they let you print your own Postage and
shipping labels right from your home or
office it's ready to go in minutes so
you can get back to running your
business sooner and here's the best part
not only is it more convenient
the prices are better with rates you
literally can't find anywhere else like
up to 84 off USPS and UPS
84 percent
did I read that right yeah it says 84
percent
must be a typo
nope that's the real number 84 percent
off
plus stamps.com automatically tells you
your cheapest and fasting shipping
options so you can compare
and contrast they've been in business
for over 25 years and they are
indispensable to over millions of
business owners one of which is Dad's
lovely girlfriend
that's true she used this at home
she does what she she smells art right
prints and stickers and all that kind of
stuff and so she does a lot of shipping
and she does it all with stamps.com
with stem
they get sent you a digital scale you
weigh it right there
then
you know exactly how much postage you
need to print it out put it on the
package
you either put it in your mailbox or a
Dropbox or
you can schedule a pickup they will
literally come to your house and take it
come on
give me a break
yeah
give me a freaking break dude take it
easy get out
stop stop it
set up already right
set your business up for Success when
you get started with stamps.com today
sign up with the promo code H3 for a
special offer that includes a four week
trial
plus free postage and a free digital
scale there's no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com Click
the microphone at the top of the page
and enter code H3
thank you thank you to stamps.com
who we love so well
yes okay
I'm feeling that beat
um
yeah so
[Music]
I've got here by the way I don't date
crypto Bros
this is on the website right now and
that's true I don't think I'm so glad
you clarified
I was I just want to make it clear
crypto Bros are off the menu that crypto
[__]
yeah you guys can visit teddyfresh.com
there's all kinds of fun stuff up on the
website right now
jacket
oh this one's sold out
don't they [__] yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you get it you get that yeah
but also speaking of Teddy fresh check
this out Olivia was featured in a Teddy
fresh ad it came out so nice
I was so excited when they asked
came out so nice thank you it's on
Twitter and Instagram so fun love this
photo
thank you which is your favorite photo
of the ones here I think the last one is
my favorite just because I love the
jeans and the buttons so much on the
cardigan this is yeah that's a nice
photo
yeah the slayest
I love them all but that one with the
flowers my favorite it's so cute I think
Macy or Kai put all the like butterflies
on it I think it looks so beautiful
that's awesome oh thank you Lena they
did a really good job
hmm
so here is this thank you also I want to
give a
shout out to Olivia because Ela posted
this one
and you did the makeup for her he's been
playing around with makeup and fashion
and all this I did we we've been or
she's been experimenting with some
makeup artists for the past few months
and so we've been sending looks back and
forth and one day she was just like do
you want to try and I was like sure and
so I'm not a makeup artist by any means
but I did arts and crafts and it was
very fun slay Queen
you gave her that Jack Frost yeah I was
I tried to put glitter on the eyelashes
on top of the white mascara but you
can't really see it but I think it looks
like
I think so too and everybody actually is
loving this look she could make anything
look good though
I could have drawn nothing
okay and she would have been like makeup
by Olivia and people would have been
like so amazing no you did good though
don't play yourself sir you know what I
mean you did a nice job
so there it is
a little recognition there
thank you
hey I saw this on my Tick Tock feed do
you guys think this is this obnoxious or
is this like
this girl posted
okay this this is really funny so here's
the first thing she posted
which is her dancing oh she erased it
ah
it was her dancing in Costco it's it's
still up for me really yeah I just
opened it weird oh I just refreshed so
here she is dancing in a Costco you know
like you do
yeah whenever I go to Costco it just
breaks out into spontaneous dance
I just love the deals
so she posted this
and I think the comments were like girl
what is wrong with you these people are
just trying to shop
[__] annoying
actually I saw a lot of commas being
like this is fire I don't know what Euro
this is just it's so to me the dancing's
nice I'm not criticizing the dancing
it's like why are you doing it in Costco
you're trying to make a point that like
you're willing to
disrupt other people it's funny or
something but it's so embarrassing
mostly look at the caption
finally here's the result dancing in
Costco was such a challenge
why what was what was challenging
well part of that was challenging
blocking the entrance that's always
congested I'm sure it was a little
difficult
yeah it's not really a challenge at all
it's just embarrassing you just walked
into a Costco and danced it seems pretty
straightforward well this isn't the the
funny part uh
everyone's good Costco is going to raise
their prices now
everyone's so negative because there's a
time and place for this and Costco is
not one of them people have busy lives
and are just trying to shop okay uh King
thanks for breaking that down for us
but some people loved it they said this
is so satisfying to watch I go watch it
on repeat all day
but this is here when it's went sour
okay
she posted the BTS now I saw this video
first and I thought there was somebody
in Costco
who saw this crin [__] going down and
captured it but she filmed this and
uploaded it and you can really get a
sense for how
embarrassing this whole thing is so here
is the video she posted
dude it just it's like without the
Cinematic
uh
without the filter and the zooming and
[__] I mean it's so embarrassing
so embarrassing
Jesus Christ is that just hard to watch
yeah I'm pretty sure this is illegal in
Sweden
the eagle
well you're like in Sweden everyone just
kind of keeps to themself alone
it's a very incredible Society people
would just Keel over and die if they saw
this yeah I love how people are just
like I'm not looking at this train wreck
whatever it is I'm just trying to do
live my life this guy turns around he's
like I don't want to be involved in
whatever that is she's also in the
pathway leading to the checkout lines oh
she's at the front you think yeah well
towards towards like the registers and
stuff you see how like usually it's the
directions the carts are going I guess
right no you're right that's the
checkout yeah yeah which is already
hectic enough oh and that's a full
Costco right there boy yeah
I go watch this on repeat actually all
day but isn't it funny how everyone's
like I'm not even gonna look like you
know when you see like a dangerous
homeless person and you're like I'm not
even gonna catch eyes with them it's
like that
I don't even want to catch eyes
I'm just gonna pretend that this isn't
happening and this is from October 2020
too so
oh this isn't even a new one no from
2020 so this is like height pandemic
right around there that's even worse
you're right the mask etiquette is
really good here also if there's a sign
in the background of the other distance
oh somebody know is this covid related
it does it seems to be here's my
favorite move by the way I have a
favorite move
let me find it this one
check this out
right
wait that wasn't my favorite move guys I
need to go back
it's hard to catch [__] did you guys
think of that move how about that one
no no I'm just gonna let it play okay
and then I'll tell you when I see my
favorite move
dancing is cool if she's in like a dance
studio this is dope there's no problem
with the quality of the dancing she
knows how to dance but it's just
obnoxious
get the [__] out of the way crew only
show when Esteban says
probably when
the hell freezes over I'll freeze is
over got him
foreign
do you hate me that much Esteban when
the [__] are you leaving
if you don't like me don't want to just
say it bro
when the [__] can we do a show where
you're not there oh thanks bro
this is me when the crew takes over the
show and fires me
it would be like the office without
Michael Scott
so after season seven
not as good when it sucks when it sucks
so true
I I thought D'Angelo Vickers would have
been a good character if they continue
on with him
I don't even know who that is it's how
much I don't care for those Seasons Will
Ferrell oh the guy was there for two
episodes right but I don't know I felt
like that could have been fun who would
who would that be to you
who do you think could replace Ethan
Zach of course
no it'd have to be somebody outside
somebody outside of us let me out the
side the show that we just bring in as a
new Ethan uh-huh who would replace me
Zach go ahead you want yeah this is very
on the spot right now go ahead
no one
to answer the question
you passed the test
[__]
now why are you bothering me I'm at
McDonald's trying to enjoy my lunch
number nine
wait hold on
we need the beeping noise dude I'm
looking at ambient McDonald's noise
10 hours oh it exists of course
kill the music there
Omar as authentic as possible can you do
the fire shot Ian I like that one better
[Music]
it's the cardi B meal
thank you
[Music]
the best deal on Earth
who has the ball to do this
nobody's brave enough
oh there's like the people that always
get into fights at McDonald's
that's what we should like ab and I
should go over there and just like start
a fight right behind you
mm-hmm
[Music]
I don't know anything about that funny B
but she sure makes a mean hamburger
youth are actually growing up
really
yup just take some videos okay I'm
staying on this
what'd you say uh love
these are going up these are going to
stop doing
considerably
I know
I knew a lid
[Music]
see it it's not funny and then it
becomes funny
[Music]
Zach is the guy outside laughing asking
for money
thank you
[Applause]
hello
[Music]
these are still going out yeah
foreign
[Music]
thank you
um
[Music]
everything
um
[Music]
foreign
I love you yeah
[Music]
beautiful
foreign
[Music]
that's not
required
thank you
it's powerful I ate all the food there
was no food left
I don't know how we do the show without
you man exactly bro I Dare You by the
way I ate this whole [__] meal every
goddamn french fry wow
committed to the role listen no other
show would dare to produce this kind of
content live it just doesn't happen
you understand what I'm saying
why not I wonder
I think he's kind of cool I think it's
Brave and daring and avant-garde
something you wouldn't understand Dan
I'm on the bleeding edge of Comedy you
understand me
[Music]
um
all right where were we
um the girl dancing right
so it's like that
that was awesome
[Applause]
yeah also now so you guys know that my
personal Tick Tock got banned from Mass
reporting from tater tots now our
podcast Tick Tock got banned from Mass
reporting on tater tots so we we we are
one million podcasts followed
account my 2 million followed account
has been totally eliminated I have no
one to talk to I have no recourse
whatsoever Tick Tock is our home it was
my home I wish it was you know they
should be [__] paying me
for I'm you know the the listen if
there's a tick tock Army I'm on it
in the war against triller you know I'm
saddled up
and this is the thanks I get
the one response I got was use the when
you log in use the onboard tools I can't
log into either one I'm totally out
totally banned yes yes
it's just there's no respect
and love how much effort how much work
you put into that Tick Tock account
brother
oh he's gone
I think I went to McDonald's
well a lot he put a lot of work in
so if anyone from Tick Tock is here
please we need you please
dude that game we're gonna play is going
to [__] murder me after I
oh god what have I done
hey you guys know Steve will do it I
love talking about Stevie boy
little Stevie boy so he's he moved to a
new
uh streaming
so are they doing content video content
and live streaming on Rumble yes
with a whopping 8 000 subscribers this
commercial has four million views
and 3 000 likes and 300 comments
does that does that
those numbers don't quite add up to me
yeah but this this is the um
wait is this for K okay Robert let's
watch Hello I'm Rumble and I'm YouTube
YouTube why are you dressed like that
well I've been seeing a lot of
violations in the community lately so
I'm enforcing that you mean like people
not following your policies strike one
uh what if someone tells the truth but
it's labeled as misinformation
wow what if I want to ask questions and
have different opinions on things strike
three
now what you may appeal to me in 30 days
thankfully we encourage diverse opinions
and new ideas thankfully we and we
encourage Nazis and pedophiles uh
we encourage new and uh diverse ideas
like Isis recruiting
and drug abuse drug use of illicit drugs
on camera
and gambling without any regulation
oh dude what there's no such thing as
four strikes and I'm not even on your
platform
all right I'm out you're crazy later
dude sexy you know
it says it all that their spokesman is
Steve will do it
you know what I'm saying
is their celebrity endorsement Jeffrey
dahmers yes Steve will do it got banned
for
um
I guess promoting gambling
on his channel
and linking the gambling so here's
Rumble
looks great
right
looks familiar
well it looks it looks like a [__]
1990s video sharing site
yeah
so let's see who's live on Rumble
titty streamer or well yeah I guess
that's what you call it 13 washing
is that uh insulting they call them
titty streamers oh no she's actually
just doing ASMR
pre-recorded
yes so
Steve is uh here's his page
40 000 views I see it I see this coming
back
okay guys this is the official Steve
will do it podcast and is brought to you
by happy that hard Seltzer if you are
listening he's the cool dad bro you
notice that dog never leads the side
five stars the full video is on my
Rumble Rumble fine Dan it's Rumble Steve
will
so
um here he is he's he's blowing up on
Rumble
you know love that
good for him
they did a whole series of commercials
about it
and this is part two but yeah I think
the view count is odd I think they must
be promoting it or something
somewhere like as pop-ups
but the the very fact that they're
hosting it on YouTube kind of disproves
their point
they're like we YouTube silences people
critical of them and then it's like
no that's like a whole genre of YouTube
videos
I'm surprised they don't have like a
category for it on the home page
people [__] on YouTube
look at this top comment these dudes
have balls to put this on YouTube and I
respect the [__] out of that where else
they gonna put it Rumble nobody's
watching it on Rumble there's a reason
it's on YouTube
and it's not because they're Brave
[__] hilarious
yeah so Rumble
not to be confused with the one that
Aiden Ross and train are pumping which
is like owned by steak that's kick
that's kick yeah there's a story about
that too that's a good segue
yeah that one's [__] crazy dude
but there's a whole series of this hey
YouTube what are you doing oh I'm
updating my content policy dude that
logo makes you want to die
is that the worst
wait why is it a d
or it's a play button yeah
I think that's the idea YouTubes is a
play button
these commercials are like complete
rip-offs of the old apple vs Mac
commercials yeah yeah I get what they're
trying to do but then they brought out
Steve will do it as the supposed to be
the Slick cool Mac guy yeah
money you might as well bright out like
O.J Simpson
hey YouTube what you doing
you know
and uh
please wow that's a lot of pages oh yes
what about you I don't see you working
hard in your content policies well here
at Rumble we try to keep our policies as
simple and consistent as possible our
policies hasn't changed much since 2013.
yeah that's because nobody watches your
[__] [__] YouTube has tons of
policies because their business is super
complicated and they operate in like
hundreds of different countries
and also they have a ton of advertisers
that expect some resemblance of decency
oh there's a question is Rumble
available in uh the EU try it love you
got Rumble and Sweden I'll try it
huh I changed mine today really do you
mind if I take a look sure
yeah this is what happens Rumble when
you have traffic on your website
it is I can access it yeah yeah I don't
think they care much about it
one more this is a new one thank you
I'll block off my score
page 94 is my personal favorite okay
can't wait
[Music]
but I love that and in this sketch Steve
is still going to read it all because he
wants to
you know participate on you he wants to
get back on you yeah time to break free
he's interested Steve and I I think it's
a good moral Steve it's time you start
reading
the [__] rules because obviously you
broke them and got banned
so I like the message here it's actually
quite nice
I love how this was tons of [__] I
love how this was a very subtle way of
trying to insult YouTube without getting
completely blocked off the platform
it's very subtle
you may not have picked up on some of
the nuances of this sketch but this is
in fact about YouTube
yeah
they guided that yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh it's an ad so they're paying YouTube
okay that explains the massive views one
of the only ads I didn't skip
holy [__] that's smart
hey YouTube a shitload of money
[Laughter]
that's interesting technique that was
awesome
what's ironic is the creators whose
videos these roll before are going to
make a lot more money is going to get
paid more from Rumble than they ever do
on their actual platform trying to think
but nothing happens
yo this one's Wild
you see oh this one looks cool hey
Twitter world it's me OJ
you know wait there there's a connection
there wasn't he didn't they have them on
the their podcast oh yeah no right yeah
I don't know if Steve was there but no
he wasn't over on Rumble I can talk
about how I severed my wife's head
there's no content policy that prevents
me
from you know
she's talking about that
I love OJ
straight up just a [__] double
homicide murdering freak just walking
Among Us I love how it's playing golf I
love how subtle you are calling him a
murderer
yeah if you launch carefully there's a
little bit of subtlety here
living his best life
awesome
the American dream right there my
friends you know
um
did we watch this one
dork [__] weirdo what is this outfit
Steve you're on TV
is that outfit like dorky as [__] shorts
in a in a top I guess neon the socks are
colorful I mean it looks like an outfit
I'd wear something yeah that's I didn't
want to say it but it's it's something
I'd wear for sure
hi welcome to YouTube thanks it's great
to be here I'm just gonna upload my
video right now let me see it first
oh wow no you oh no no that has um you
drinking until you nearly die and also
gambling on unregulated websites what
the [__] bro
I can't post that why not I don't agree
with that nope okay I'm sorry
yo what are you doing I'm uploading my
video all right that's a warning pal
dude you need to relax
flag what okay you want to get crazy
did you just cancel me
all right I'm gonna be leaving now where
are you going to a place where I can get
canceled and they celebrate Free Speech
Free Speech being
promoting the unregulated gambling sites
steak.com getting penile margarine
scissors was six nine
that is free speech believe it or not
Dan I agree and there you can show on
Rumble
you can
get a big fatty is it a big fatty [__]
with your boys
isn't it so beautiful that six nine and
Steve will do it our friends like I just
think that that that proves that you
know there's good things in the world
but in Fantasyland it's not Fantasyland
it's called Rumble later I I go like it
could be a rumble where Free Speech
lives and also the Holocaust didn't
happen
they celebrate me for that
foreign
I like I like where white supremacy is
openly talked about advocated and
celebrated
freeze Beach
new ideas
yeah Lisa he at least he um
he accurately represents how he ignored
the warnings of YouTube nope okay I'm
sorry this is his rep being like Yo dude
just so you know if you post another
link to a gambling site again you will
be banned sorry he's like sorry what are
you doing I'm uploading my video all
right that's a warning pal dude you need
to relax
flag what okay it's crazy right
it's so stupid
is the other guy somebody known or some
random actor I think he's just some
Rando
some Brave free speech Warrior yeah he
didn't get paid for this job he did it
because he believes in the message
you know
so actually that leads into another
thing I want to talk about then we'll do
the beer pong
um what you got
okay so there's another new platform
that's made by stake.com the unregulated
crypto Casino headquartered in Curacao
in a small Hut oh yeah actually it's a
nice hot let's we've corrected the
record on that right right right
recently painted recently painted pretty
nice hot crispy
it's like a studio home
maybe like 500 square feet it looks
small but I think it's a more like it
looked more like a one bedroom to me
than a studio one bedroom yeah maybe
you're right like 800 to certainly
enough to run a billion dollar company
out of enough space there yeah so Aiden
Ross
and train wreck the two guys who were
getting paid the most money from
steak.com to promote a unregulated
crypto gambling to their fans are now
being paid from by stake.com to promote
kick.com which is just like a total
[__]
three skin of twitch
but this should tell you how much money
they stand to
gain from doing this like
this is so pathetically obvious what
they're doing it's there's just so much
money it's like they don't even have a
choice they're like okay I'm banned so
here's what we're gonna do we're going
to build a new website how much do I
need to pay you Aiden Ross to switch
over he's like yo twitch is my home okay
five million dollars a month oh kick.com
baby
done because you know it's like that
and I'm not exaggerating there was
leaked texts of Aiden saying he makes
two million dollars a month from
steak.com
2 million
I'm going to kick this week
um I'm gonna be doing Omegle watching
live sports watching movies illegal
illegal prank phone calls
potentially illegal depends on the state
unlimited we can literally watch porn
together I could jerk off with you no no
I'm still celibate
a bit but we want there's no terms of
service over there you guys that's not
that's not
that's not the brag you think it is
exist
there's no terms of service
they make no claims about what they do
with your data how they share your
personal information or even if they'll
pay you at all for Subs there's no
contract
it's awesome I should say whatever you
want to watch nobody that can't be true
there's got to be a terms of service
on kik.com that cannot be true there's
just no terms of service that seems
[__] insane dude
terms of service over there you guys can
say what do you want about chat nobody
can get [__] bad
if you listen nobody's getting banned
you can say whatever you want
awesome bro oh and they do because it's
just full of like n-word and slurs and
stuff right
I saw a picture of his chat and it was
just
let's see apparent okay so they do have
a terms of service oh this is community
guidelines
okay so hold up the phone here Aiden I
think you gotta check these General
restrictions
kick prohibits activities and materials
that are harmful deceptive offensive or
illegal I think you can't even be
offensive on kik.com what the you
literally can't who decides anybody
they're not going to no offensive speech
whatsoever no hateful speech okay that's
half of ours
right our users it's just a fact in my
opinion here it says you cannot violate
violate our terms of service what terms
of service interesting
what terms of service you cannot
copyright you cannot
stream copyrighted material this man
just said he's going to stream the whole
[__] Super Bowl that's not
copyrighted right that's that's public
domain
the Super Bowl he says you can't do
nudity this man just said he jerk off
for you yeah
involved in or promote fraud scammer
deception see that is a little like
shocking that this is on this list
but this is the core business model
right here you cannot defame others
yeah well I know definitely the owner of
this website I'm just kidding
they cannot you can't operate lotteries
or sweepstakes or you're talking about
yourself look in the mirrors
no doxing
no misinformation nope no fake news no
Russian propaganda they're just like
every other site dude it's literally
they just don't have mods
okay let's read copyrighted because this
gets really good so Aiden Ross legit
live streamed the Super Bowl
the most popular broadcast every year in
America
that people the whoever broadcast it
pays billions of dollars for the right
to broadcast it
their top user Adam Ross live stream the
[__] whole Super Bowl to a hundred
and ten thousand viewers this is insane
this is [__] insane
it's also mentioned in the terms of
service that you can't do that as well
according to Aiden Ross gotta highlight
it right here hopefully hopefully in the
coming
um depositions they'll play that clip of
Aiden Ross being like there's no terms
of service we can watch movies we could
watch the Super maybe they'll use it as
a defense and plead that he's well [__]
If he if they have communications of
them telling him that then that's not
going to look good for them
here's the terms of service
okay we found it there are terms of
service should I send this to Aiden
should I send this him a picture of this
you could scroll down to 2.2 instead of
that quite extensive I might add there's
a massive terms of service it's so
there's so much that it's like lagging
the browser it might be the single
biggest terms of service we've yet seen
I don't give a [__]
right it's just not what you said in
your video
so you have to so do you think it says
in connection you have to have the
written consent of each and every
identical fightable person
to use their content surely he has the
written consent of the NFL in all of the
individual players at that every single
one
the coaches what about the ads
yeah no he got those two he got uh John
Travolta and kiss he has an extensive IP
team Adam Ross
it's a whole department
that's awesome yeah I don't know how
this doesn't lead to them being
absolutely [__]
streaming this well you gotta you gotta
find them right right I mean it's so
true
but here's the thing
I'm getting sued by cavcv for streaming
for not even I didn't even stream it I
watched a clip of it
and now they're suing me because there
was an unlisted video with like I don't
know 50 views or something from us doing
research
so I do think that Aiden Ross can be
sued individually for this this isn't
just a
actually I think he is solely
responsible for streaming this because
there's this law that prevents uh
Publishers for Publishers from being
held accountable from what people put on
them right
[Music]
so
I actually
I think there's a good chance you get
sued for this
we said it's copy pasted from twitch TOS
is it really just quick to us you can
see somebody in the chat said that
that'd be really funny if so they're not
going to train which is too restrictive
I'm going to kick where they don't have
anything else that board the copy pasted
TOS from twitch yeah the good thing
about kicks they don't enforce it
here's train wreck also streaming the
Super Bowl
I'd love to see them get sued to be
honest
that'd be awesome the damages on that
it's got to be insane 110 000 viewers
that's gonna be a lot of damage yeah I
mean I don't know for facto
likely it is but the NFL definitely has
a reputation of like
being very very protective protective of
the copyright so it doesn't seem out of
the question the thing is I don't think
they would care if it was like 300 or
maybe even 3 000 but a hundred and ten
thousand people watching a live stream
that's nuts
I think NFL if you are watching this get
after them I'm tired of being sued for
[__] this is actual copyright
infringement
thank you they're not going to we'll see
about that
it's just a fact in my opinion
just a fact in your opinion got it I
don't think it's taken from the twitch
TOS but actually I am now picking up on
the fact that uh
it probably is just like a template I'm
seeing certain like
phrasings although I guess contracts
sometimes do this
like deep down in it they're just
referring to it as the company like
almost as if it's supposed to be like
find and replace you're supposed to put
your company name there
dude this is insane
so Austin Knox have been tracking this
so apparently you cannot ban or censor
stuff because it's like free speech
apparently that'd be you know
that really can't show
the chat then no no no I can't
or here I'll just make it really small
so or here I'll just put it like this
and I don't think you could read it but
yeah so it's just a ton of racial or
[__] I'm an idiot
help me and do something it's just not
this would not have it on the screen how
about that yeah so it's just a ton of
racial slurs
says Kai is an R wordest spam oh they
have
why the [__] does a swastika have an
emoji
like wait there's like a built-in one
bro look at this screenshot there's a
straight up people are spamming
swastikas as one character check it out
stop dissing the Nazis all the time is
there a Unicode there might be a Unicode
there's I'm guessing it's like a code
one Indian one right and I think it's
just generally disallowed turned off on
most places but they don't care they
allow dissing the Nazis all the time so
people are spamming uh swastikas
they're saying they're spamming the
n-word as he's sitting there with his
black friends
calling them the n-word
um
great
train wreck again okay so here's train
wreck who's now switched to kick
this guy how this guy has any fans is a
[__] mystery to Me Trinity
acknowledges the issue kick has with
fake viewers counts and the number of 15
to 20K
make sure that
I'm transferring with you guys looking
to find a fix stuff like well
I mean I think the fix is you stop
you turn off the fake view counts that's
the fix what other figures I'm trying to
be how do we stop these I don't know how
to stop these fake views on this website
I'm deeply involved in [__] and this
viewbotting stuff like
you know I'm pressing for that as well
even though I get heat for even speaking
about it right but that's like that's
what it is like I'm gonna speak about it
because at the end of the day when I
attach my name to something you know I'm
going to make sure that I'm transferring
with you guys and I tell you guys what's
good and what we're working on and what
we're going to try and fix so
I mean it's like I'm sorry this guy is a
[__] psychotic freak he is a i he
seems he strikes me as like a high
functioning psychopath he he has no
moral compass he'll say and do anything
to justify his disgusting involvement
he's fully in bed with steak.com this
man is a [__] sellout both in spirit
and and uh tangible
money and soul bro like realistically
I'm Gonna Keep it a buck but right like
yo I used to say that I'm bringing it
the truth to the management here they
don't even they get mad when I even
bring up the fact that there's Bots but
I do it anyway bro thanks for the two
million yeah keep the checks coming I do
it anyway man but they [__] hate my
guts for it
yeah three million please so I'll just
put it in my bank I'll take the the
direct deposit yeah they hate me over
here
but I love you guys
if this dude if you bought a two to
three k viewers I might just say [__] it
I don't give a [__] but when you're view
about 15 to 20 [__] thousand viewers
a day to push predatory gambling styles
to the top I don't like that so I'm
gonna actually oh my God you know uh
find a fix for that as soon as possible
especially since my name is attached to
it and since I'm you know pretty much at
this moment the face of it so it's like
uh you know It's just tough because he's
literally in an ivory Tower
he's like on the top floor of a giant
beautiful modern building looking down
at the peasantry
so awesome why does it lie
oh oh this is interesting
Jake lucky I asked an attorney about
Aiden Ross streaming the Super Bowl and
if he could be sued
well we all know the answer to that but
let's hear it from a lawyer yeah
attorney for that but he's like actually
it's totally legal anyone can read 100
let's go I think attorney Tom here so I
saw last night a couple big streamers
rebroadcasting the Super Bowl in real
time to hundreds of thousands of people
their justification for these actions
was that their new streaming website
didn't have a terminal
dude these people are [__] dumb
dumb
so dumb
oh that wasn't even steak it was dual
bits that was paying him 2 million and
he's so sorry the correction dual bits
was offering Aiden Ross two million
dollars a month in a leaked conversation
he turned them down because he wasn't
enough money to compete with what stake
was offering him
oh prohibited so it's even more than
that yeah so it's even more than that oh
it's such actions
but
the problem with that it
'd be right in French doesn't matter
what the terms or conditions were on
that particular platform because the NFL
is the one who owns the copyright so
unless they got permission from the NFL
to re-stream the game in real
that is likely copyright infringement
with damages in the millions and
millions and millions of dollars yes the
only hope that these streamers have is
that the NFL does not pursue legal
action because if they do yeah they
could be in real trouble yeah they're
this is what cavcv please this is what
real copyright infringement looks like
and they are
Mega [__] if NFL pursues legal action
Tom here and in a way I think they do
because these guys need the [__] a
reality check these dudes really think
they can do anything on the internet
they want with no repercussions and so
far they've been right
the two of these guys
they're not going to
steak was probably like we'll cover it
we're made of money dude we'll send them
some [__] Ethan call it a day
yeah here it is
there it is pretty funny in my opinion
[Applause]
kick.com baby
let's see the one I've actually never
been on the website there is currently
five people streaming
you know
um
if I apparently if you search for Aiden
Ross it doesn't even show up
he's not Aiden Ross the top G with one
follower so Aiden Ross comes up oh
that's got to be him Aiden Ross the top
G Aiden Ross but he doesn't even show up
oh
how bad can their search be
it's their biggest user
and you're following him or no wait what
why does it say unfollow
on Aiden you see that let's try it
wait what there he is if you go back you
you were already following him on the
other page it was maybe a bun
it's this is I'm not following again
I've never even been on this website
unless one of you guys did no you're not
even logged in which would work
I don't know what you're trying to say
exactly
not it was official bug probably but it
said you were following him but whatever
so Aiden Ross okay so here he is it
showed up when I just type Aiden oh
cause it's one word see yeah that's
that'll trick any uh search engine
Aiden Ross one word it shows up of
course
awesome
well looks like he was smart enough to
at least erase the VOD
of the full rebroadcast of the Super
Bowl
you know how people like when you can
stream oh [__] people are typing to me
now on his stream
let's not do that as We Know
what can show up there
you know when you're streaming things
illegally
not that I would know
but
hypothetically it would take you to like
a really [__] weird website that's
hosted in some weird country
obscure tons of pops up super spammy
it's rare and frankly fascinating
in this case that Aiden Ross has done it
right on under his name
so I think that's an interesting
strategy
you should start re-uploading Seinfeld
friends
people can come visit Aiden Ross's Kick
profile and watch all their favorite TV
shows
any you know what I mean just just
request to upload the whole season for
you guys to enjoy
it's expensive to get the NFL ticket
prices are part of your cable
so Aiden Ross has actually pledged to
stream every game of the season next
year
so you guys can just watch it live over
here
[Applause]
that'd be nice for him
they found a loophole there's no terms
of service you see
oh [__] that shit's crazy all right
thank you thank you
with peace
and
love
last episode we
Joe Rogan was taking down these deep fix
of himself
it was him oh yeah it was him promoting
a scam fake supplement
and we said let's get these two guys
talking about something that they would
never use and we decided like mascara
so somebody actually did it a cliff
diver King uh here is Jordan and Joe
Rogan talking about their favorite
cosmetic products Cara that is very
interesting they work very well to
increase lash length by about 100 to 200
millimeters well look that L'Oreal
telescopic life mascara is all over Tick
Tock if you go to Amazon and type in
lash extender for men you're gonna find
it right at the top and that's because
guys are figuring out that it literally
is increasing length and making a
difference of them it stimulates Queen
Behavior if you know how to slay have
you heard these statistics about Olivia
no I didn't what about Olivia well it
turns out 95 of the H3 audience agrees
that she's slays and if you take this
angrily that's basically 100 wow I know
you know what why doesn't Olivia do a
weekly makeup tutorial she just keeps
sitting on her dragon's horde of sleigh
totes me goats she needs to spread that
Riz to the rest of us
okay wow
[Applause]
it that looks like
very legit those men have never held my
attention for that long right yeah they
should consider going into the Beauty
World they might I would like to see
them in in lashes frankly I would as
well I like that oh I can show you that
oh Jordan and drag yeah love that
trans men and drag are destroying
Society slay Queen any man who's put on
fake lashes deserves to burn in hell for
eternity I want to meet him
I don't want I don't want Jordan
Peterson I want I want that Jordan
what's the concept of lingerie before
your mirroring his daughter put him in
makeup for fun legs for funsies yeah
imagining you have a vagina this
perceptual kick oh there was nothing
sexual about that but they're great it's
between your legs
absolute Liars
I like how Jordan is just at the whim of
his daughter she's like hey Daddy
well you'd eat just meat for five years
for me no
yes yes sweetie Daddy can we go to
Russia and do you on experimental blood
transfusions l-o-l yes we do
dad while you're doing experimental
blood transfusion to fix your opioid or
your Valium addiction can I go uh run
around Europe with Andrew Tate and as
you're on your deathbed yes sweetie yes
yes we do whatever you need princess the
female dragon energy
Gina oh you should give me that clip of
him saying that women our word needs to
be looked at as property damage
rather than
uh Jordan is getting into it with Sam
Cedar uh on Twitter about that actually
right now uh I saw it right before we
went live oh I want to read that I love
Sam Cedar you know he'd be a good guest
I wonder if we could he's in New York
though right yeah he's in New York I
wonder if he ever makes it out here
it'll be a fun we could see if he does I
mean he
he probably does every once in a while
I'd like to promote him I like his show
and yeah watch it he's a king yeah I
think they're all trying to uh like him
and his crew are trying to bait Jordan
into a debate that will never happen
unfortunately yeah he's too much of it
but it'd be so good of a giant wimp
yeah so there it is we should actually
maybe consider putting this and sell do
we have a product that we can sell
to scam people and talk with a fake ad
yeah I don't think that we need a
product to sell we just need an idea of
a product Oh wait we don't actually have
to ship anything that's the beauty of
the business model dude
no overhead the only obstacle in our way
is that we just don't have a tick tock
account right now
we haven't zero accounts right zero
accounts lots of ideas
maybe it's better we posted from a
random account
hey Rochelle uh in Canada thank you so
much thank you thank you
for the gifted 45 please
um yeah send me the original I'm not
looking for it with commentary
you know what I mean
yes so Jordan Peterson was having this
conversation
and he's like I want to push back a
little bit you said that
female empowerment
had one benefit just one
which was that
sexual crimes committed against women
were no longer looked at at Pro as
property damage here's something else
that's
but they were looked at as a crime
against a person and I want to push back
on that a little bit he literally said
that
I think I've I think I just found it I
want to push back
dude by the way so he has this show on
The Daily wire
and he shoots it where they both look
into the camera
and it's so unsettling all of the uh
that's that's a stylistic choice that
they make on The Daily wire because all
of their shows are very like Square
interview shows yeah I've seen other
I've seen clips of um
who's like the third rape guy
there's there's Ben and then there's
Matt Walsh I know who you're talking
about and whoever the [__] that third
guy is I've seen clips of him doing that
it's very unsettling to me because it
seems like I'm cosplaying as like Jordan
Peterson which I'm not
right
go ahead play it pondering you know you
talked about one of the advantages of
the sexual Revolution was the
transformation of the idea that rape was
a property crime let's say into a crime
against the woman herself and I would
say look I have plenty of Sympathy For
That perspective
and I think it's fundamentally true but
but I'm going to push back but you know
why this is all very complicated
are women property it's a very
complicated question you see
yes sweetie dad can I put you in Drag
and tuck your dick between your legs yes
yes sweetie of course
try to keep going oh here I found the
original so I can talk about one of the
advantages of the sexual Revolution was
it
you know it isn't obvious to me this
section by the way is labeled as the
plight of the unsophisticated female
what
it says
do we have any unsophisticated females
in here of course not so we can't we
can't answer this one let me can't speak
on that is rape a property crime swear
to God that's the question
that's [__] wild bro
I mean you really need to watch it you
just look at the labels and then this
one is listen to your mother
yep
so uh
he's [__] insane ever since he joined
the daily wire he's gone so so so so
crazy
but it's not obvious to me that that's
sufficient like maybe
of a society where something that will
bring the males on
in order for that to be if
you know it isn't obvious sorry I'm
trying to find the right spot it was
there let's say into a crime against the
woman herself and I would say look I
have plenty of Sympathy For That
perspective
and I think it's fundamentally true but
but I'm going to push back because you
know don't this is all very complicated
you know it isn't obvious to me that
that offers women enough defense
you know and so the counter argument
might be if the thing is if we consider
them as property and bear with me
men will be more likely to defend them
like they were a Nintendo or PlayStation
you know how hard it is to get one of
those things still out of stock
now I can guarantee you if my wife if
someone was molesting my PlayStation 5
I'd be there faster than lickety-split
bucko
but if my wife was getting assaulted
well it's her problem according to the
sexual Revolution
foreign
sexual access to a young woman
is a crime
in order for that to be recognized as a
crime properly
it has to be
viewed as something that will bring the
males on her side to her defense in
principle
of they wouldn't they wouldn't defend
her
I speak for myself when I say
I could not defend a woman who was
assaulted unless I owned her there's no
interest I have no interest we're
talking about before the show and I was
like
I was genuinely trying to be charitable
you know not that I sympathize or agree
with his point of view at all but just
to wrap my head around what he's saying
and like there's no interpretation of
what he's saying other than women would
be better off if they were property
because because men defend property
that's better for them that's the point
of view that's what these sick feminists
don't understand
it's a psychotic the sexual Revolution
turned women from a commodity into
actual people and they've never been
sadder
all right wow now maybe not right
because you could say well maybe we
could set up a society where merely
quote transgressing the rights of a
woman to say no is sufficient but it's
not obvious to me that that's a bro what
the [__] yeah
that's not sufficient she says no that's
not enough to stop most men
sure hasn't stopped me
Jesus what's not
like maybe sufficient means not only do
you violate the Integrity of the woman
in a fundamental sense but you enrage
all of her male protectors because right
now I wouldn't really be angry I'll be
honest
I tell my wife to get over it
now if I owned her
and I knew that she had some kind of
street value some kind of resale
secondary Market I'd be a lot more Angry
you understand
foreign
dude Jordan not everything needs to be
questioned bro
disagrees and then that's enough of a
barrier because God only knows how much
barrier we need that crossing a man is
is is much more difficult much more
taboo
and obviously well you just laid out a
bunch of problems especially now that
the pill introduces I didn't stress that
see I feel like he's talking to me I
didn't do that
I feel like you just laid out a bunch of
problems Ethan what
just watching
the problem that women have in saying no
once they're on the pill is that it's
instantly personal
and that means the woman has to deliver
a pretty hard blow and that's especially
problematic if she's stuck
the pill
the problem with the pill is that she's
got to break the bad news the tough news
to the man
she doesn't want to have sex and well
you know men take what they want
[Music]
unless it's property they obey the laws
of property it's also like why is he
talking about this like this is the
hypothetical this is literally what
things were like
prior to like ago 60 years ago also why
are we grouping in being on birth
control and revealing that you're on
birth control before having sex when
you're also talking about rape and what
it means like those are two different
items I'm so different like I'm assuming
he's saying
because they're on the evil pill then
men will be more incentivized to our
word them because there'll be no
consequence
because there's literally no other
connection yeah right
the pill is evil I'm listening yeah no
he's
everything he said from the beginning I
stopped listening dude he really
is so [__] up it's insane like again
it's like Jordan do you think
there was more
or less rape in the Middle Ages than
there are now
oh significantly less because they were
property yeah it's like what are you
through the man well I think we have the
entire history of humanity as evidence
for your theory pillaging what did they
mean by by rape and pillaging I know I
know they use the same word but that was
different it was used differently than
it meant to rape meant to rape seed they
took their oil
rape scene right they took their canola
oil yeah no the etymology I don't even
think back then they even like really
had this concept of rape like it was
just like
you're sexy and so far as it was like he
said it was property this is his this is
his ideology he made all of this up like
I don't I don't think this is real at
all it's not something
to
to be a philosopher about its gross and
it's horrible and end of story now
people always ask me what to do about
the Jewish question now I I push back a
little bit on this
now I think like hypothetically if every
Jew was exterminated I do Wonder
if we would live in a more prosperous
Society Society
the Fatal flaw there would be a lot more
space
and your living space uh
dude he's [__] crazy and then if you
go to his remember uh his interview with
see everyone's so cowardly they
interview him and they act like he's a
normal guy but he's not he's so [__]
up yeah he did that podcast with that
guy uh that MIT guy there everyone
thinks is so smart
he wears a suit oh uh Lex Freeman yeah
yeah and all the comments were like this
is the most important conversation I
think every comment section of every Lex
Freeman video has is just full of people
wow unbelievable if you're so smart
let's talk about this [__] you know what
I mean
[__]
the thing is is that he's so wibbly
wobbly on what he but like anything
you've you see it whenever he gets some
pushback
he always falls back on that he's always
hedging like even when he's talking
right here
he like says all of this insane [__] and
he's like or maybe not
like it's just a thought experiment but
I don't know but what if we castrated
Every Woman
just remove the clitoris yeah just
thinking out loud here it's just a
thought experiment yeah totally you're
right and his follow and hit the people
who love Jordan will give him all the
grace in the world
he didn't mean that bro
somewhat potentially interested in the
guy right how do I say no without
hurting his feelings alienating him
making him into an enemy looking like a
prude and I mean when you're 16.
everybody thought of how the feelings of
the rapist
right
right it's frustrating we need to stop
dissing The rapists what the [__] have
you it's frustrating to hear no
and then you realize she's on birth
control and you think
well
there's no downside I don't see the
downside she's no one's property
I'm not stealing anything
you don't know the answer to any of
those questions like you're not why is
he wearing airpods
the only thing I can think of is that
someone's giving him show notes the
devil it's his daughter his daughter
just puppeteers him like a [__] like
a meat puppet at this point but the man
can't me yeah exactly right someone's
got to be giving them producer notes
yeah I guess it's just an ifb or
whatever but it's just it looks terrible
and makes a real sense better ways to do
it they have the money they can afford
real life bees so
put in these iPods they make me look
cool and Young
you don't need to wear those we're not
going to use them damn it they make me
look hip
put them in
and I saw this in my clinical practice
all the time you know I had lots of
women at my clinical practice who were
abused serially
and you know they were generally
stunningly unsophisticated in their
conduct and I'm not trying to blame the
victim I'm just whoa dude this is
shocking
this is utterly insane
low class they were low-class women
coming in what
holy [__]
yeah we've seen enough of that
enough of that
whoa
that actually was worse than I thought
yeah he's psychotic I love this there's
a little self-report in there he's like
I have a clinical practice and women
would come to me who were serial abused
and I would sit there and judge them for
being idiots
I was there to help them
but I'm secretly despised them
they didn't get better by the way
they made no progress yeah that's so
stupid it upsets me so much that he
thinks just because women these women
who are going to him for help that all
of a sudden he knows what's best for
them or that he can speak on behalf of
women
yeah what a freak dude
such an important conversation
I want to push back on that a little bit
could this woman that he's talking to
like push back on him at all I don't
know I couldn't even watch it yeah now
most people think you need to drink
water to survive and I I want to push
back on that a little bit you know one
time when I was uh 13 I went two whole
days without a sip of water
and I wonder how long could I go maybe
maybe I don't need water
just a thought experiment
thank you
well that was depressing
you know
yeah I know I'm putting off the beer
pong bro I don't want to do that [__]
I'm wasting as much time as possible
you're trying to wiggle out of it no no
we'll do it we'll do it Bruh Bruh
should we do it I mean yeah we should
probably just do it
uh I mean what about the UFO [__]
boring l no UFOs they aren't aliens
they're [__] balloons next LFO LFO oh
really you're gonna tell me it's a
weather balloon Dan I am
well there was something on one of those
balloons I did tell it was like a hidden
message on there what was on it uh Zach
exactly if you check the album I mean
yeah I guess let's look at the pictures
of them whatever just so we can like
judge for ourselves
we have pictures right here there's an
album okay here let's take a look
all right you guys probably all heard
about
these mysterious objects being blown up
by the
government
and people are wondering what is it well
what are they doing here's a picture of
one
okay
here it is falling out of space
this was the first one I'm assuming
here they are retrieving it yeah
okay take a closer look
enhance
Zach Lewis live at Rock oh whoa no way
whoa
it didn't say that yeah it says it right
there it looks totally fake come in dude
the aliens
that is fake as [__] shout out dude wow
thank you aliens
that is not real they're fans
far out bro all right dude
wait hold on do it do a pull real fast
do you guys want me to cover the UFO
[__] or just get into beer pong
you guys decide do you want me to cover
the UFO [__] won't fit so just UFOs
no get into beer pong
um
that's right
I mean we'll do both
but uh
I don't know
[Music]
maybe not the UFO [__] is old news there
to say you know what I heard uh
interesting theory on the UFO [__] what
you got
they think I've they think it might just
be trash that's floating around up there
yeah because they tweaked the radar to
make it more sensitive to [__] they
weren't looking at before when they shut
down this balloon
and just because they started seeing
[__] doesn't mean
anything it had has been there no and
apparently there is a considerable
amount of trash floating around up in
the skies
well ultimately I hope so because if
they are aliens uh then our whole like
first Contact scenario we've completely
[__] blown shoot them down
immediately like they they've traveled
ten thousand they've been in cryo sleep
for 10 000 years traveling from some
distant star and they finally land and
they're on their way to Washington to
introduce themselves shoot them down
stand up they have 22s the Chinese the
Chinese they have a great taste in music
though we'll say that thank you yeah
shout out shout out even worse than
this is a robot that's been going planet
to planet for a trillion years yep
building building using the resources
going to the next planet
this intricate last effort ditch of a
distant civilization the only other one
in the whole universe they saw us right
and they said as their Planet died
collapsed from within like uh Superman's
World Krypton Krypton yeah they sent one
last desperate plea just to put out a
hand and say hello we were here we
existed right maybe the maybe the last
child of that Civilization just like
crypto it was flying there's a little
baby the last baby was flying down or
maybe they should have stayed the [__]
away from America yeah that's what's up
dude y'all [__] up yeah I know it was
Canada but that's basically America so
gift booked
Trudeau said we could shoot you down
so I think it's just trash probably yeah
or if it's not it's definitely a Chinese
not that interesting right
garbage garbage
bro I'm getting annoyed that nobody's
talking about that [__] in Ohio
I'm waiting for the daily to do the
podcast about it this morning they did a
whole [__] episode about Bing sucking
Bing's dick promoting beans because
they're they're implementing AI into the
search engine yeah yeah and um they
[__]
episode about being bro and they don't
even mention it in the footnotes how is
this possible
yeah
has uh has our boy Mr Mr Pete mayor Pete
made a statement about it yet last I
checked he hadn't even commented on it I
don't think buy it I don't think Biden's
commented on it either I think so that'd
be a good deal why
is there any news coming out of East
Palestine perch you guys see that
picture from like overhead where it was
like a passenger airplane like no yeah
the the uh in the summoning of the Dark
Lord in Mordor show me a place in uh in
eastern Ohio right now I'll try to find
it uh I got it I think I know
holy [__] it looks crazy
everyone's like uh
everyone government's like I enjoy it I
didn't see it
sometimes you just sometimes you just
tear open the seam of reality into the
[__] immaterium and let just pure
[__] Despair and hatred leak out into
uh the Midwest I think this is the
beginning of the Avengers
that's insane it's just like it looks
like a raw negative energy to Earth's
butthole dude look at that thing
puckering up
whoa hey
that is literally Neil bent over this
happened
right
yes somebody said the gates to Oblivion
that's right
oh my god dude it's so disgusting
and don't even get me started on more of
mass shootings at schools somebody said
it's a sky prolapse
um Sky prolapse that doesn't sound too
bad is it a prolapse of pleasure or pain
ow might be fine ow ow
[__] disgusting
if you go to New York Times They even
have a single like article about it
disgusting let's find out
because
let's go to the New York Times front
page and see what's big stories right
now yeah uh debt ceiling Bing oh no oh
Ohio town where the Train derailed
anxiety and distrust Run Deep so that's
on the front page it is on the front
page okay so what toxic chemicals so
good for them let's see about Washington
Post
maybe it is breaking news Bing
the search engine is now trending big
time everybody's buying Microsoft
[Music]
IO train derailment one hour I think I
think it's finally starting to break
through I think enough rumbling has been
happening to people being like what the
[__] is happening but uh
they're starting to talk about it a
little bit I actually I read something
really compelling it was like even in
Chernobyl the Soviets relocated the
whole town
got them apartments and a place to live
that was away from the radioactive
fallout here in America names on their
own that's just how it goes well that's
um no help no support chevala or some
something right is it okay maybe I
mispronounce it shavola
shavola or some something in America
these people get [__] off help
they're God damn dude
here's a here's a message from from uh
mayor Pete
rip Bozo he said of the residents of
East Palestine that's [__] up
he does not give a single [__]
dude that that's insane he tweeted that
that's super [__] dude
I know you don't care but don't tap
dance on the disaster of Christ's sake
yeah so uh
at least the Soviets cared about their
people man USSR forever he took the
Soviets nine days to evacuate
nine days yeah so how long are we going
on this one
um I think it's at like 12. so
can you imagine that the Soviets were
just like I think we would be talking
about what monsters they are but we do
this [__] every day
and also how long ago was that you know
and also it's the [__] Soviet Union
right they don't give a [__] they're
like they're like
somehow they cared it more
Vladimir Putin even Vladimir would have
evacuated
we basically nuked a town three more
chemicals discovered in Ohio train
derailment
quote unquote oh
really this guy is somehow getting worse
silk cagiano a hazardous material
specialist said quote we basically nuked
a town with chemicals uh-oh so we could
get a railroad open
there it is people I believe an
individual citizen in this country has a
right to own a nuclear warhead
well it ain't freedom
you know what I mean you chose to live
here in East Palestine you know what the
risks were
that's what freedom is brother
hell yeah what the [__] is this what is
this can you decode this for me CAM I
love posting this oh what is that yeah
it's like uh the wave Shake meme I don't
know I thought it was funny wait he's
got a wave wait why did you drop it
though why
I don't know I thought it was funny we
were talking about the iPad or the I I
think he's everybody
because he's cool oh it's like a meme
swaggy I wish we were in USSR right now
bro we don't have any con violence and
these people would be out safely already
three days ago
Back in the USSR you are dragging you're
free okay all right let's do it let's do
it I actually need a minute to switch
over the cameras inside I'm gonna go pee
as you set that up
I don't want to drink this [__] [__] me
how do we choose teams
okay I'm gonna go pee and then we're
gonna play this horrid game
sounds good welcome to the cruise show
everybody where it's always kind of
awkward we're in Ethan goes pee anyone
here from Arizona
uh at least a shot at least I
appreciated my deep fried meme
it's just it was funny it was good I was
just confused thank you oh okay it was
very funny look oh thank you guys thank
you I I give a little bit of a try you
know usually cam does that kind of stuff
and I was like yeah I see I had a vision
and it was like you gave it I commend
you for it you gave it the old College
try
Zachary Lewis live at the Rock seek
if I puke ahead of time do I have to do
this and I just you can be disqualified
well I don't think that's a
like goal of the game it's a puke or not
I I think it's just like
we're just trying it you know well I
already have to do it you'd just be a
massive [__] if you didn't oh oh
you guys are confused I am okay with
that what's wrong with the [__] love
nothing it's just funny
what's that print song uh maybe it's
like [__] something
I don't know I don't know uh I was just
watching an interview with Jamie Foxx
and he was talking about it
I have to check it out
you should perform it at your show yeah
wait uh where
um at the Roxbury the Roxy right yeah
Zach Lewis live with the Roxy a 13th
nice it's gonna be grand old time power
ticket Zone do you know they are going
off the shelf like uh well we didn't
call it hot cakes but um room temp cakes
yeah let's go yeah so you want to come
good time good Tunes
I will be going through the Roxy two
nights in a row that week that's right
literally the night before yep it's
playing I'm gonna see covet play and
then I'm gonna say Zach Lewis live at
the Roxy bad [__] ass my guy
I know I can do to kill some time
what do you guys think of these I just
got these bad boys did you print them
yourself it looks like 3D printed don't
they yeah see I love the easy slides but
obviously I'm not buying any more Yeezys
and this is like the Adidas new version
I think without Kanye okay it kind of
looked like a fish though now that I see
them in person they look a lot cooler
online
I think they're cool I think they're
sturdy it's definitely a sturdy shoe
it's not comfortable it's not what you
wear it's what you wear it with there
you go yeah there you go make everything
work together
facts facts facts
um Ian is helping Dan right now so the
camera's just Frozen on me how you guys
doing how's uh the fight training going
baby it's good man I don't know how it's
gonna go after today's episode that's
what I'm really nervous about to be
honest you have a training
yes sir yes sir hey you know something
part of the reason why this crew stuff
is so awkward is because we have a dock
for the Regular Show what if we start
preparing a little pee break doc you
know the pp dock the pp dog so we're
gonna have a little discussion topic in
between pee time interesting idea
Cameron what do you think
it interesting interesting I don't think
it even takes that long you can talk
about it well you know just something to
jump through for when when it's peepee
time right check this off
check this out kinetic sound
there we go very nice love
did you buy just buy that love
yeah I bought a bunch I've been I've
been on that ship for a while because of
Theodore oh yeah I never tried it before
he loves it
I really enjoyed a Theodore's joke
yesterday hmm or I'll play it for you
guys
as we set up
so those are all room temp uh
where this refrigerator how long they've
been
[Music]
what
there's so much weird [__] here
oh I didn't even mention that we're
trying to get our third baby we'll talk
about on Friday
when he was here
dude this is so [__] up you guys
foreign
we were on the members episode yesterday
remembering remembering this cream pie
image because I I mentioned they were
trying for a third baby
I tweeted it to Markiplier actually did
he ever respond I made it so only he
could respond
let me check I think he's playing hard
to get with me
you remember Marco plier said he muted
me
after I tweeted out the cream pie [__]
and so I thought hey what better way to
memorialize
our third baby then
sending mark this
zero responses damn
I think he's uh doing the interviews for
the crater Clash maybe I could ask him
in person
uh oh you have to bombard him with it
just say bro watch this and then show
them the video on your phone so he can't
escape it
be like yo bro I'm a big fan I just have
I wanted to show you this video I made
yeah and it's just the cream pie donut
thing I love that Meme that we got to
try to get this in front of him as much
times as possible
I actually love that idea
you guys hear this with the audio it's
insane it's the most disgusting video
ever made and it's just donuts
[Music]
okay well um everything is prepared yes
we just Sam are we
okay just one more minute
we gotta draw teams and everything all
right so let's get going on it let's go
wait I wanted to show the theater oh
sorry I gotta click this wait what what
does this exist oh [__] this was so fast
how'd y'all do this so fast
[Music]
wow this is awesome
this is incredible wow
I'm trying to find a joke that Theodore
told
[Music]
see
someone just sent me the link before I
say
the joke that Theodore told me
[Music]
okay
yeah Theodore told a joke there was a
clip on the subreddit
you know
[Applause]
nobody sees it I got it thank you
here it is
okay so someone asked can you tell them
a joke
why did the cookie go to the top okay
why did the cookie go to the doctor
tell them
oh you tell them it's your joke
okay it was cloudy because he was crummy
let's go
he's been telling that joke for a while
that's his standard because it's
faithful that's an old really it's an
old-timing joke
it's really good
I think the first time he told me that
he didn't even know what crummy meant
it's so cute he just heard it somewhere
I think in a cartoon and just held on to
it
all right let's pick teams Sam [__] you
so gross
uh this is the grossest thing I think
we'll have ever done because like you're
have to chase it
[Music]
I think you tempted her a little bit on
the uh Thanksgiving episode
you were kind of complaining a little
bit about some of them so I think she
stepped it up
and I'm [__] horrible is that what
happened Sam
Well everybody's in this one
this MMA fighter says a b beats dad and
here's why
you see that post I actually Dan showed
me before the show and it was very sweet
thank you dude that was very kind it was
nice to have someone be supportive so
thank you we all support you no no I
know I mean just someone who knows
boxing it's nice to hear someone that
knows something about it talk about it
rather than just bro dad's crazy
foreign
[Music]
let's pick some teams out
intro go ahead roll it I mean we're not
Pick scenes or anything
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
welcome everybody to the first and
hopefully last
cursed beer pong
today we will be picking teams randomly
and is this a bracket or I'm because I
there's ain't no way I'm playing more
than one game so your incentive the
incentive is for you to win if you win
you get to leave oh you lose you've got
to play again yeah
all right so I'm gonna pick for teams we
have the big Maga hat of course as
everyone knows it's impartial
it's great we're making great and doing
America that's great
okay so so what does this discernment my
partner uh
bands yeah so grab one for who Dan's
partner is fistful pairs
Dan is going to be paired with Ethan
what the [__] it's destined all right
you good at beer pog
no no you can't be that bad
I'm okay I'm okay at it Lena okay Danny
Nathan versus Lena and oh we're the
first game I guess
Olivia
Cheryl's Boys Rule Girls Drool
all right so we can pick the other side
of the bracket okay the other side of
the bracket is going to be
Zachary Zachary live at the Roxy the
foxy Roxy May 13th May 27th
May 36.
Zach and a b let's go baby
what a nice what nice pairings this
Hat's putting together
Ian I believe that's all that's left
how fortunate for Sam why do you not
play fam
just because you made it doesn't mean
that you're
Pam no she got to drink this [__] and
Ian so there is our first two brackets
so first up I guess are we ready to go
we're ready right Sam we good yeah all
right so uh Olivia and Lena step right
up
bring your game face
[Music]
because I am playing for keeps
oh yeah
[Music]
uh wherever you guys can do this we're
gonna need do we have a puke bucket on
standby yes okay good
but let me see my shot
how are you guys feeling
um
nervous for sure are you guys good at
playing beer pong experienced at all I
have not played I used to play football
cup God that's the only game I've played
the sense emanating off that I is truly
[__] I can't even look
oh no no no well Lena we know has like a
an iron stomach I don't think right now
no
get in there it's like a yogurt it's
like a yogurty yeah
oh brother okay so the rules are when we
sink it you drink it
sink it you drink it so how do we decide
who goes first let's just stick turns
just go back and forth
whoa bro I'm tripping on the table bro
it looks [__] trippy as [__] my eyes
are actually tripping out on that one oh
so oh I when I was in college we would
bounce see I don't even get the ball no
bounce you know what you guys go first
okay you right
I'm bailing after you've drank yours no
come on
okay Olivia gives it a kiss
sorry sorry I'm so good at this I don't
know what's wrong oh well some of these
I'm not allowed to eat right they're
Mark okay which one is that what'd you
hit so I got uh the sub Primal punch I'm
good
okay we wanna you gotta lie about your
credentials this is the one that's like
uh it looks like Ethan's pesto [__] can
we get a visual for the people at home
yeah well we have this overhead camera
I'm not sure
good you can see it there no we need we
need to show the jar you know what I
mean
there you go Dan will be consuming
uh they're a stool sample of my little
warm I noticed but
okay what's it smell like
to be honest it just kind of smells like
pesto okay maybe it's not bad
oh it's so thick it's still not that's
not right that you make it so thick Sam
it tastes like beef jerky
turkey
you're really chewing a lot it's chewy
it's chewy so he might have to
so why don't you tell us about I have
the list of uh that was the subscribable
punch you said it's a subprimal punch
okay so apparently in that one is beyond
meat uh horseradish see I was wondering
because it tasted kind of meaty I
appreciate the consideration beyond meat
horseradish vegan fish sticks spinach
and oat milk shame on you God damn
that's I feel like they'll be worse like
this is not good but I feel like
there's Works in store than that all
right well I guess set it aside uh yeah
okay certainly don't have to drink all
of that it's lingering man it's
lingering and we're not playing the bat
we're not doing the bouncy balls yeah I
can't stand close to it
come on it's gonna be embarrassing wait
all right well we'll deal with that
later wait where's the what overhead
this camera right here oh you guys can't
see that
here we go
[__] oh sorry sorry it's all right all
right keep it going so now Lena has no
game there's like there's chunks there's
chunks I'm pulling out of my teeth here
okay first of all watch the elbow what's
wrong with it the elbow can't cross the
line and I'm not I'm not playing this
before I mean like I'm not playing cute
little beer pong games any other rules I
should be aware of just yeah now you
can't cross this line yeah okay you got
it thank you
why am I so nervous hard throw it harder
than you would expect
[Music]
oh
that's okay that's okay nice try all
right Dad you're about to see why they
called me magic fingers in college oh
yeah oh [__] why they call you magic
fingers
hopefully it wasn't his girlfriend
it's actually my doctor oh
Kobe Kobe
oh that was close that was close wait is
it are we missing out with the overhead
camera oh I'll work on getting that
fixed
because all right you're drinking next
anyway so keep it going all right so we
just keep keep it going
you suck you got the
Olivia sucks lame you suck at makeup
first time just lame
oh yes I can when it hits the rim you
could swap it smack it you girls have no
idea what you're doing
if it hits the rim I can slap it okay
Ethan's 100 right I'm a pro player
Dan I just did a beautiful play
what does that mean do I have to drink
something no no it just means you didn't
go in
dude somehow this water is already so
vile looking Dan should I shoot for you
yeah just yeah just keep it going
Kobe Bryant Spirit of Christ Kobe Bryant
the spirit of Christ lead this ball
praise be
to Allah
oh wait what is it you taught me
yesterday inshallah inshallah
okay
yes you will
let's go your elbow was past that line
all right well we're getting [__]
destroyed
laughs Klein wine
getting high up your own Supply
biggie says I shouldn't drink this
Biggie Smalls
ten Crack Commandments
it's oily
God damn it
I just had so much [__] McDonald's
you'll like this one
that's an interesting smell
they all do
kind of earthy
all different flavors is there olive oil
in this
[__] me it's so hard to drink it magic
fingers magic fingers magic fingers
magic wow I feel like I'm back in
college
what do you think
I want to die
I need something to wash it down real
quick no that's cheating you have your
high C and your uh cope by cardi B yeah
oh this one is Coke Zero olives what's
your favorite pineapple jalapenos cheese
and broccoli
okay you know you do a good job of like
they're all palatable ingredients yeah
which is nice it's the combination but
when you put it in it's just God [__]
curse yeah
that's why there was a familiar
smell to it it's fine wine there you go
all right am I am I throwing again that
was so [__] yeah you're up we need
one dude we need one so bad
come on I think I told you it wasn't
good I just don't know why these girls
lied about the credentials I've been
doing you guys are the same trick since
volleyball in fourth grade when the
girls would serve I'm not telling you my
secret but there's a secret word I say
right before and you keep wait wait
what's the word so what's the word I
need the word
literally never played this before okay
fantastic great so you're total you're
totally new at this and you're way
better at it than us that's very cool
beginner's luck every time with beer
pong
okay and by the way you're only allowed
to kiss it once not three times did I
kiss it three different I'm just fine
I'm just making a rule is it mine yeah
I'm just being a PO I'm just being a uh
poor loser all right this is it you got
this dude you got this um
you need the power of Bobby Bobby this
is why I'm watching this is
oh no
gamer girl bath tonic that sounds nice
it kind of smells
good
it smells like perfume kind of
so I get to go again right because I
sunk it
yeah we haven't yeah we have been
switching off but whatever that's how it
is oh thank you what does that mean like
once I got when you get it you get to go
again oh have we not been doing that no
yeah no well we'll start now that I did
it
sip this go ahead I'll show it off to
the what's the jar
yeah
let me see it's still yeah the cold
stuff out of my teeth
that one looks pretty vile
wait you guys can't see it here higher
up
oh what yeah it looks like oh my God
all right Bottoms Up
no problem
oh we got a little bit of a gag
she's good horrible horrible yeah the
worst what we got uh that one is
chocolate syrup aloe water and goat
cheese
oh yeah
that means a lot coming from you the
worst part is not knowing what's in it
you know yeah so do we remove the cups
now yes or okay so wait we only made one
cup we've only made one dude it's sad
one cup I was worried about this taking
a long time if
if it's going real slow maybe we can
swap out once we get five cups one cup
one God okay
this guy is on fire and that's why they
call him magic fingers people
now you know why
somebody
[Music]
the stuff that gave Kavanaugh and a
legend uh DUI allegedly
can I drink this is it alcoholic uh no
no
this is not too bad
it kind of smells like pickle juice Lena
loves this [__] whatever it is it's
actually really good I would drink this
at home yeah
Oh wrong reaction from Lena which is a
little bit sour just a little sour it's
a little sour but it's okay so it's got
to be pickle juice right now
what was in it Ian that one is Red Bull
salt lime olives and mini Martini onions
oh
maybe it's just the onion yeah that got
to me
all right
let's just not lose again you guys know
I can lock it up right now right that'd
be great
oh my God my God
damn
foreign
magic fingers
you should go back to college Ethan
you would do very well
milk nectar okay that one does have
happy Dad in it
I think I'm not driving home so you get
a little toasty
it smells kind of like
Christmassy that's nice yeah
it has Donny's jizz in it I also smell
almond like a lot of almond
hmm
you sell do you smell dog semen oh my
God
oh but the little chunks were really
really mean they're all so junky they're
all so chunky yeah what is enough nectar
so that one is happy Dad Seltzer
pre-workout and a protein bar oh I like
that
you're just doing milk yeah just meal
prep that's that's what they do with
breakfast right yeah what are you
talking about he slams one of those
every morning
he's on a hot streak
be the ball
no feel the ball no I'm giving you my
energy no no
it's okay it's okay it's okay so we had
to end some time it's okay
now it's your guys's turn whoever went
just to speed it up oh
oh it is oh you're right God it's been a
while so Olivia you go now me yeah oh
yeah because you can sink it into the
same cup
yes no no no no no no no no no
not happening all right Dan all right
it's time to it's time to redeem myself
a little bit here
try
it's my turn oh
fear me
okay cool yes
okay we were gonna speed it up a little
bit oh
nice try
all right power through power through
here we go yeah so uh incredible work
in real time watch that just watch that
elbow girl
I look watching it looks good I'm
looking at it doesn't look good to me it
looks Over The Line
I think it looks beautiful nobody care
about the rules okay
it's me I believe yeah we have got
oh it's the gamer girl bath water so we
already know about this one
uh cool what was that one yeah refresh
us on the gamergirl that one was
chocolate syrup aloe water and goat
cheese
until the goat cheese it would have been
fine
the way it's all Blended up makes it so
[__]
oh
that is powerful
the second it hit my tongue I almost
threw up yeah it really it just happened
like I
was it my that's where it's us again
right yeah I guess so that's great fear
me
yeah this is my favorite game
okay
oh God
that was a I would say I would say that
was a good try but it wasn't all right
thanks team that was a [__] Terror
how many cups have you hit again pull it
together dude
exactly zero I know you're carrying fair
enough you need to step it up come on
dude
all right I need the power of Bobby
Bobby
I'm going to talk about the allegations
right now
most I've ever cared about a beer pong
game now so important to me I have a
quick little note uh Lena did make a
shot and she didn't go for her second
shot after the make so Lena will get two
shots okay okay that's fair
this is kind of tough how they're spaced
out what are you allowed to oh my God
that was more like that Lena yes we love
it are you allowed to uh to re-wrap it
when it's a makes a perfect
okay
all right here we go
straight to me
uh and now you have one oh [__]
Olivia oh oh Olivia Olivia
oh straight straight shotgun blocks all
right let's pick this up lead it up lead
take us off yeah here we go
sync that [__]
that was a super good Miss thank you so
much
every every time
never mind do whatever you got to do I'm
telling you whenever you have to do
you have to do you do it I'm drink too
oh my God so this is the fourth
this one doesn't smell bad we can
rewrite good we can re-back now no
decline of climb one let me guess all of
theirs is like Sprite and ours is
actually [__] up it smells like salad
dressing and as a reminder it's Coke
Zero olives pineapple jalapenos cheese
and broccoli that's mine the Ethan's
Pizza okay it's my dream beverage
if I was in The Matrix that's what I
would eat for every meal
oh
it could be worse can you guys re-wrack
please yes if you have to make a pyramid
for us
got it thank you okay well did I do it
well or no no no let's tighten it up a
little bit that's not up to regulation
no
tight those cups need to be touching in
the middle they're all touching in the
middle they got to be touching they're
not touching they're good they're so
close to each other oh I see what is
this a little death trap for our balls
what do you need
see
yeah I know you're trying to cheat
that's what I do that's what I have I
know so certainly what I had all right
you want to start Dan uh
uh is it us uh Ethan gets another shot
because he made that one right oh right
yeah oh [__] keep it going dude
miss it
oh [__] okay hey who sneezed back there
okay we
keep it quiet no sound stirring we're
shooting what's so [__] complicated
about that [__] quiet back shut the
[__] up
the party atmosphere is noisy
you should be able to play this is a
deadly serious game there's no Wimbledon
there's no [__]
player dude
am I allowed to do um toss it like that
uh I think so yeah you can throw it
however you want [__] it
yep
hit us wait did you shoot yours I didn't
yeah yeah you did
oh oh Olivia oh I'm close
a sniper shot a sniper come on Dan all
right I got at least one it's so embar
you're on that clock tower
I'm getting that Book Depository boy oh
come on baby I'm up on the I'm on the
grassy knoll right now let's go
one shot one kill bro
you've been training for this the Magic
Bullet here it comes
I'm hitting the rim
don't get too down on yourself every
time you're right there you're right
there
guys there's no Whispering Allowed no
there's there's no spring allowed
oh yeah
[__] yes yes sneeze guys let's go sneeze
all right I do want to say think about
this before the show and I knew that
nobody was good at this and that it was
going to take a while I do think when we
hit five that should be
the team swap out I love that because we
just need one more right and they need
two more right yeah they've got them we
have two throws the thing about beer
pong
is anything can happen we should have a
total amount of shots you guys are
allowed until you all have to just drink
oh that's cursed no shut up Ian what the
[__] I do not like that rule I don't
like it
oh that's so close
okay and I oh
what's your profanity
oh
every you know what eat it you know
where were you
scared I was looking away so this is a
new one
another kind of milk another kind of
milk oh wait is this the one with Donny
Seaman uh yes yeah that's right so we
need one more too that doesn't snow
oops the sponsored I need one more wait
we're tied no no I think that we've only
done three oh yeah no we're tired we're
tied now we're tied oh perfect yeah you
guys have done four this is the fourth
cup on our side it's okay there is a
melt there is another type of milk in
this yeah
it's a yogurt it's a yogurt beverage no
there's there's no semen in this just to
be clear
silence Dead Silence
from Sam
told us to be quiet
you think
it's his mouth his jaw is quivering
[__] you
oh how is this really salty yeah what is
that just mean it's fermenting on its
own like yogurt because
super salty but that one is uh oat milk
salt aloe juice and goat cheese again oh
the goat cheese what's with the goat
cheese and uh Zach semen it was so salty
all right so they got four so we we
gotta re-wrack this one right well they
gotta ask for it Dan hey could you
please re-rack could you please re-wrack
you got it thank you so much thank you
come in right Dan you [__] you come on
bro you have to ask for it
you gave it away for free
foreign
literally as close together as possible
you are pyramid challenged no who wasn't
involved in the game yeah
let's get him Olivia's what's up she
sucks at makeup she sucks at everything
she is super lame and thank God that was
way too [__] close all right it's us
now yeah please we're back just we're
back baby just end it we're back baby
and this nah I've been doing the I've
been doing love this get it I Gotta Get
Loose yeah just just feel it you know
it's not really a trip but I don't aim
for a specific cup me too just shoot for
the area just the general area I have
been focusing on a single cup so maybe
that's not worth it nobody's that
precise
yeah
come on bud
one [__] cup
come on
come on close it was close it's always
close it's not good enough close doesn't
okay good enough game first your last
what time is it it is 4 13. all right
well sorry guys gotta go
this is the one this is what gets us out
of this about like three more turns each
and then if we get this that's five cups
I say we're out oh okay
let's go
oh yes this is the thickest thing I've
ever seen right it is that's what she
said it didn't it's floating in there
God damn bro
[Music]
how'd you even drink that it's not
liquidy enough oh really wait
I think you drank this first Like
Biscuits lava the pesto oh I I had that
one
you know that was less bad than the
other one than I had I had the the
second one you had too but this it's
you'll see
I'll meet you there yes
I needed that and this was beyond me
horseradish vegan fish sticks spinach
and oatmeal these it's just vegan fish
sticks
what's wrong about vision
my face is like this
no pretending either you better down
that it takes a while to uh Slither it's
right back
oh [__] she's gone she's out
well so is that it so so here's the deal
there was 10 total we just got our fifth
they went first by the way so there's no
response no excuse no response
no bro they went first Ian they went
first there's no rebuttal
the end thoughts that we've had equal
shots who are you whoever you always did
a rebuttal someone has to start first
who are you to decide that there's a
rebuttal in typical beer pong rules no
but they went first bro but also you
guys decided Midway through the game
only five cups so true and also I didn't
get a second turn when I made it
first time facts that's all right no
excuses just throw your [__] balls
and miss
deal watch your elbow
you're not gonna get it you have no
chance stop kidding yourself
suck
[__] that we'll get it
nice try Olivia oh is it my turn I guess
so one more rebuttal I mean you don't
have to shoot if you don't want to the
outcome will be this we're gonna do this
do this for all the women across the
globe you want to do the other
underhanded again no no
[Music]
sorry to all the women
that's goodbye
so we have to play the next game I think
you you so what I think we should do is
you stay in until you get your fifth cut
and then the other team will come over
so you still just need one more wait
what there's not a new game now
wait dan you're making up [__] up what's
the rules he hit the he the original
idea was we were going to do this whole
thing twice
I mean this is taking we can also we're
horrible once we hit five we could Tap
Out start doing it like we planned and
what's next what's the new team right no
no teams that's not what he had planned
you're saying let's do it the way he
didn't have a plan come back you just
said yes wait no you guys are out I mean
we did five cups right you complete the
game's over you and Ethan don't have to
drink any more [__] you're done okay
so I mean that that was
I thought but now everybody just tell us
what to do Lena and Olivia uh uh you can
take a little break and then the other
bracket goes
okay yeah
good game bro
it's Gigi's I mean Dan didn't make a
single cup so you win against the best I
mean yeah ggs everybody
Houston's a cheater shut the [__] up
chat
literally magic fingers in the house
you're intimidated by my raw power
I'm so over it I'm doing a lollipop now
Gila brought me this lollipop yesterday
for Valentine's Day go baby
all right we need to uh yeah
now let me ask you guys yeah okay we're
good does anyone here think they're good
at beer pong excited once in my life
Zach has been I think so craving all
morning about those Gucci glasses no
they're Lucci
I can't go over this one this is going
to impair their vision and then Ian I
see has this big lag on
got my pink set on where did you get
that when you're with Jimmy or you went
and got it got it okay I had to travel
to the holy site you know over this
right did you get a dog
no you didn't get it though I'm just
here for the Hat they don't I don't like
their dog his photo is on the walls how
do you do that you can't trust their
food if they any establishment they will
put a frame photo of Jimmy Lee on the
wall not a trustworthy establity he
really convinced him he's famous that's
awesome okay how do we who goes first
you guys usually in beer pong I thought
you shoot and look at your opponent just
let the Blues Brothers go first here you
know go ahead [__] dude just go ahead
you wanna go first stay shaded
we won and didn't go first so it's not a
curse that side of the table one person
is elbows what watch your [__] elbow
Zach he's like six five
give him a break sorry it's a nice try
buddy thanks good shot now you go right
go ahead I don't want to go
oh [__] you know these call me in
college Old Miss shaky hands
Butterfingers
holy [__] that was bad Jordan balls too
that's maybe the worst shot of the hole
yeah whatever you want to do it's a good
lotion all right yeah keep let's go yeah
come on okay
yeah all right
Bobby oh son of a [__] that hit your
balls
have you all been in college I will get
there
for you
now you're getting your experience yeah
you're the only one I can't judge
[__] my tender [__] all right hey
guys the idea is to get the ball in the
cup
it's okay oh that's what we're supposed
to do hold on ready here's how it goes
[__] hey dude I just do power shots
okay
I saw it
all right this regulation size the table
okay let's go quick let's go quick if
this was actually taking place
break up enjoy it Zach okay hold on let
me shoot let me shoot get your balls out
of my face right there [__] get your
balls out of my face
same cup means that y'all get to choose
two other cups to come off the board
that's wait what you get three total
when you go same cup okay enjoy drinking
I've never heard of it I think I heard
of that but the game is very quick if I
drink two cups okay so Swedish meatball
Martini yeah you choose where they come
off
no no
thank you another one this one yeah this
one that was Ethan's pesto one [__] that
we got three cups off the board and one
beautiful play by Cameron what what the
Tim
yeah this one's oh they're kind of milk
okay that's a good idea actually you can
you can rearrange you can put right move
them around have we done the Jersey iced
tea no
[__] your homie you're a guy this looks
like
work with me don't push
the spirit of magic fingers was coursing
through your veins on that moment you
guys landed that
yummy not bad drink more then if you
like it so much
do you see it on the right monitor there
should be a healthy
uh yeah I didn't realize I have the guy
I'm the guy uh Jimmy Lee's Jersey iced
tea consists of sweet tea crab cakes
lemon juice and Greek yogurt Sam [__]
you
[Laughter]
you guys don't know zaka is like a crazy
Greek yogurt
wait the chance uh Zach is walking he's
out
I didn't I didn't know that was in there
and you were like take that one that's
nice that was me dude Sam set you up
Zach [__] dare you
Zach freaks at the sight smell and
thought of eating Greek yogurt get this
chase me all right I'm drinking mine
what's yours baby hold on wait hold on
back up you tasted that [__] and went
not bad at first maybe you like Greek
yogurt no
no good it's a healthy it's healthy to
eat all right gamergirl bath water is
that one right it's gamergirl bath water
yeah I don't want to know what's in let
me just read it I know we already said
it but I forgot
oh that was a good one did you drink so
much
oh [__] yeah where's the puke button
what was in that to me with my lollipop
bath water let's see uh game ago bath
tonic was a chocolate syrup aloe water
and goat cheese
you like goats
now do they does Zach have to also hit
the Swedish meatball Martini the one we
double sunk wait people are saying AB
did not drink he he totally drank it
looked to me like more than anyone is
drinking so far I'll tell you you hit
that hard
good for you wanna puke
does he have to hit one more I'm good no
we just don't no Zach yeah exactly you
gotta hit the Swedish meatball Martini
one it's uh the one on the right this
one uh you're right there there you go
is there [__] Greek yogurt in here
swear on your life
it's Swedish yoga it's Greek yogurt with
food coloring to throw you off
oh God you have to tell me that now
it's just Swedish yogurt bro don't worry
it's just it's just Donny's jizz bro
interesting
that's probably Boston Swedish meatball
Martini what's in that one so that one
is on theme with the name it is Swedish
veggie meatballs
Swedish veggie meatballs mashed potatoes
lingonberry jam and Swedish Fish
wait what's sweet oh the candy original
little candies yeah all right that
sounds yummy it's not three it's it's
probably not fair for us to go again
right no we can go let's go again no you
guys go again yeah so we both get
another shot yeah
[Laughter]
another double that was literally a one
in a gajillion
suck
better than you impulsive this one goes
out to Pink's Hot Dogs
get in his head lay eggs in his brain
dude dude Cam's trying it's terrible
don't let him that was in miraculous
that your guys has hit that same cup
like that actually maybe I should go
first let's switch to that good
[__] that [__] I'm not talking [__]
to you there we go
flip it yeah you yeah yeah good job baby
nice job
elbows elbows elbow
watch the elbows dude they're still over
the table can't do that yes he can hey
Zach come on dude
I've noticed you overshoot it every time
reel it back you're a tall guy pretend
you're shorter okay who drinks this
maybe lower your knees a little bit yeah
we'll give it to cam another kind of
milk there you go enjoy that camp
think about
um Donnie [__] in your mouth right
now enjoy that
Donnie jerking off
dude
it's for y'all trying to pick on Zach
ah [__] I my shaky heads
in your pockets yeah
watch the Jordans man in my pocket of
strategy watch strategy because I don't
have two shaky hands I have one you
don't get another shot he made it chill
out slow down this makes me look cool
chill out pinks this one's for zacher
Pink's Hot Dog boom
you say I saw
oh this game is over this game is over
that is that's five guys I'm gonna
rebuttal now Ian remember that rule you
made up on the face I literally kidding
okay yeah sure sure yes yes they can
they hit it twice okay what have you
guys got what is that Ian's about to get
rebottled
canel connector
stuff they gave Kevin true
enjoy voice
[Music]
Ian while they're drinking that restart
the GoPro
what's the problem we need a new GoPro
or something they're always touching
he's like like puke and um
like like creatine yeah it's good now
and you see on the front screen hirosis
what's a roasties it's a Jewish apple
you know all right let's focus on the
drinking
foreign
remember it's just Red Bull salt limes
olives and uh Martini don't throw up on
me it sounded like a yeah yeah I have an
AB puke on my bingo card so I kind of
need him too
wait how did you make that sound he burp
oh it's legit oh my God he's slamming
Coke Zero so he's fine he's good you're
good buddy
he's good he's good Greek yogurt all
right well if your guys's turn to shine
bottle rebuttal
come on Jackie you good man yep she's
doing great shorter a little shorter
that's what okay is up bro I knew you
had it in you you're just too tall
come on baby hand out of the pocket take
your [__] Jack why are you covering
your face
the teammates like this
okay so Zach gets to go again though
right yes
matter of fact I want to watch you both
drink that that's not how it works
exactly you can you can sink and sink
and sync like the goddamn Titanic over
there oh he's I can't even make it in
this milk nectar contains alcohol that's
probably the best one
well should I got on a different cup
yeah good [__] huh it's protein yeah
because your balls getting bigger you
know it's protein Donnie's jizz
sir
down here
you're good bro ah all right Zach you
can get a rebuttal right
if you missed this I'll mention the Roxy
more often
oh an arc you're short you're short
you're short
all right what's close you guys lost
damn gentlemen yeah game boys all right
you said if I lose more of it you'll
mention the shows intentional you tried
so so what we have a show like what now
the losers play yes the final the
biggest loser and they have to drink
everything on the board then I feel like
I'm making this up on the fly a little
bit but whoever loses the the final one
we pour everything in one cup and they
have to take I love that of the big cup
love that so
so the lizard I guess
good game guys
I love that good here
I love you but [__] you you did your
best it didn't work out for you can I
have like a beer or something to wash
this down
y'all want a happy Dad
wait you guys you guys are done get out
of there what are you doing
we're playing that
oh you guys lost yeah
never mind
can we try this side from oh no what do
you think yes well I was just getting
comfortable you guys swap sides
that's a good idea just so that there's
not an advantage
[Music]
there's so much do we have a shot glass
because if we mix it all up and then do
a shot glass
you want to do that okay for the loser
Oh I thought you want to try it uh no
Lena no yeah we're good we're good
okay excuse me
all right I'm gonna say ladies first
thank you thank you you respect women
you don't know where that ball has been
okay nice try
let's do speed ball here
okay nice try I try Zach's coming in
hey nice try Zach with the baby's coming
in
there it is your husband oh
another kind of milk okay I love it
oh my God this one smells really bad
yeah that one's all you did I've I've
drinking that one for you thank you
thank you it's uh oat milk salt aloe
juice and goat cheese
Tim do we have shot glasses here
oh I I like the idea of them drinking
through a clear glass for the final
yes yeah I could I could do this all I
need is your support
literally right here okay
Selena you're so pretty you're so pretty
you're so pretty you're so beautiful oh
my god
wow
turned up turned into a uh you need here
here
over here thank you I have to spit it
though whoa I've never seen anything hit
her like that wow oh here we can let me
move this I'm sorry
that was another type of milk that
rattled Lena
all right so you what do we do now
absolutely no someone gets a second shot
right who just made that one maybe made
that
ah it's okay beautiful throat
all right the return
all right laying out
[Music]
all right uh uh
yeah I'll go first okay
perfect just aim just aim for the middle
guys you know what I mean if that how is
that helpful or is that stupid
yeah
are you out of your mind
oh because you ate them if you want to
put it back you're more than welcome to
I apologize
oh tough luck there zacharino exactly
isn't this supposed to be like your yeah
I thought it would be Abra
it's not very rock and roll of you to
miss everything all right ladies
sink one awesome for the ladies this
one's for the girls Tulsa Bobby
that's just a little straight Lino
shotgun
I didn't
know anything nice job girls
no let's uh which ones haven't We Done
Yet
do ninjas goop please uh maybe just swap
the cup location as a fan of ninja AV I
believe that you're entitled to the
guild
you're in recovery
okay we've identified Ninja's goo and AV
is going in for the take oh hell no I
can't do this no I can't do another
another chunky one like this wait show
me the can show me the can
that I can't that last one was a guy
where's the jar you can't see it it's
just dark inside
yeah it's like a nice avocado salsa
yeah just think of it that way you want
me to do that
what a king you're gonna have to drink
again next you know that right no I'll
drink beer is there Greek yogurt in this
no but you might just
you should know that uh
I always remember this takes a minute to
get it in there huh oh he's chewing
[__] me oh my God he's chewing Jesus
all right stop it's not that bad what is
it not bad Ian what's in it uh that one
is okra G Fuel and pizza rolls
it's honestly not that bad like you will
be able to know well the problem the
next one's gonna be even worse for Ava
you know
all right so oh I go again yeah
here we go
all right all right so I believe so now
we go yeah
ah so close
that's LeBron's record
okay all right ladies are up well so the
score currently is you guys have crushed
two cups right the ladies have we no one
it's one one it's one oh it's one to one
wait I thought y'all got two cups I
don't think
oh [__] this is a sad ass game this is
the losers game yeah
okay
the fart sound the dreaded fart sound
here we go
almost got it in the water I don't know
what it means but a giant hole
we're trying a new strategy new strategy
coming out
oh right there high arc but hit the rim
come on Zachy
all righty
still one to one everybody gonna be here
a long time ladies and gentlemen I know
right I'm sorry Jesus no pressure you
got this
[Applause]
sinks it right into the Klein wine
because she could sink it sticks it in
the same one oh I go again
oh no you're broken and then she'll go
again
a fine wine
the trash can yeah
oh this one is Coke Zero olives
pineapple jalapenos cheese and broccoli
Pizza
come on where'd the broccoli come from
that ain't part of my
I do I do he's going behind the wall
guys oh that's pungent he's behind
the false wall he's gagging he's
breathing heavy that's pungent which is
it's a strong that's [__] though that's
a strong smell is that the Klein wine
yeah
he's yeah he's coughing don't puke on my
set do you want the bucket we have two
over here
okay okay
all right all right Amy if cheers us
he's not puking
okay so um you guys hit two so y'all
right you all get to go again oh right
oh true wait no you're gonna miss I got
one no oh all right right so Elena gets
another one
sorry I'm incredible at this all of a
sudden
I'm just I just want somebody to win so
I'm rooting for you guys yeah we're so
bad yeah is there is there anything did
I remove the one that we haven't done
yet I think that's the worst one do yak
and coke uh give it a nice swish
it doesn't smell that bad
he's gonna like it
he likes I'm jacking off dude
jacket oh is it like A1 yeah get off is
there A1 in here
in Greek yogurt
you didn't ask because they're Greek
yogurt
for seconds
the Spanish one for seconds incredible
it's not bad the worst one they said
what is in it
did us uh that one is
where is it oh star Yak jerky Coke Zero
A1 steak sauce and Bearnaise sauce
Bernay sauce
did you make the bearnaise sauce oh that
sounds lovely because isn't it Bernay
sauce like whipped egg yolk that's
hollandaise oh that would have been so
cursed
don't give her anything
Jesus oh by the way thank you to Johnny
Swanson for the
10 gifted
great job on the weight loss thank you
bud yeah I've been waking up uh in the
morning and exercising
how about that huh
what time you good
why do you ask that why would you ask
that I'm just curious I wake up at 10 I
wake up at 10 A.M
yeah all right so who's shooting though
yeah don't come on don't ask questions
like that oh wait wait you sunk that
yolker brain somebody said yoga brain
all right Olivia three in a row wrap
this up please how many cups you guys
got left there is it six I see or seven
seven okay so two more you got this
right now
oh nice try nice try nice try so now we
go yep take your time nice try nice try
this try it's nice try
next hook
yeah
wow
elbow watch out hello
they're gonna be having marital problems
later today
well look at me
oh that was a nice shot Elena it was
Ninja school that was a beautiful Arc
straight into ninjas goo
ninja goo is the really thick pesto one
right yeah
yeah gooey that one is
oh I keep losing it oh okra G Fuel and
pizza rolls oh that's fine there's so
many flavors all different flavors oh so
bitter flavors
I can see how much you drink Olivia from
here
turns your head good
Ninja's goo is getting off he does not
enjoying ninjas go
so gross
Ninja can control ninjas
Olivia can't control ninjas goo actually
it turns out can we smoke in here
no if we can smoke your hat it wouldn't
smoke in here yeah where do you think
you are oh it's a college party oh okay
that's fair college party
yeah
all right guys this is your chance you
can say the word yeah
come on now
okay okay dude I swear to God you're
shots there's like
they don't look like it's being pushed
back by some force of nature
that'd be Jesus like it's solid in the
air
it was weird some there's a spirit in
here against you baby all right
Olivia oh
hi Olivia
nice try right on the rim is coming in
to close this up lock it up
those balls ready let's let's do this
the ladies missed
remember at the end of the Zohan yeah
no
come on Zacky Watch That Elbow though
Watch That Elbow though
all right all right okay
all right Lena
this is how it worked dude
oh my God
this one is Swedish veggie meatballs
mashed potatoes lingonberry jam and
Swedish Fish
yeah uh
oh God
[Music]
she's running off she's screaming it's
so bad with the puke bucket uh she said
bad with a very Midwestern I did hear
that
[__] you Dan okay so wow this is a long
podcast I feel like the beginning was
like a whole different I think uh she's
gone to throw up
wow
casual looks like you're down an
opponent there Lopes you know with Lena
you just never know what to expect
sometimes she's just
what was in that one Ian
that one was Swedish veggie meatballs
mashed potatoes lingonberry jam and
Swedish Fish it's like a Thanksgiving
feast I doubt it sounds great love
that's kind of low-key racism I mean I
kind of think so yeah
sweet a phobia dude is okay
yeah but sometimes Lena she can just
take anything you know last time we did
the weird food challenge she was just
like children rally no problem but that
one got her eh have you ever seen her
puke Amy yeah yeah she she pukes not
often but yeah she's she pukes Gotta
Give It Up to her too very respectful
she ran with the puke bucket to the
bathroom to make sure
she could do it in private yeah she
avoid no puke on the floor Olivia's back
out she's cracking open a sodium she's
coming back now told me like
quick and fast I appreciate the hate
yeah yeah
now now Lena okay
now Lena while you were gone they sunk
and you have to drink
all right well now it's time to get your
Okay Lena yeah what was it about that
that set you off because you're usually
so good with that stuff
y the scent threw me off even before
going in my
mouth did you did you Yak or were you
just gagging yeah I'm sorry
well this is a true fighter a true
competitor a champion a warrior she's
back so fast by the way so fast
all right come on ladies lock it up
Selena doesn't have to eat drink anymore
oh man that was close that was close my
turn Lina come on this is
Leah can I get you're standing so far
away I wonder
stand a little closer standing far away
I'm just so Twitchy now
that's okay I almost went in thank you
guys
can we get a re-rack please you have an
interesting style of throwing you throw
with like your whole body
a three two one well ideally yeah that's
not a three two one yeah
that's not a valid rerack what are you
talking about there's too many cups oh
[__] what do I do scramble them up again
make it harder yeah you can make it a
harder [__] hey he didn't touch him
that's actually true
that's a good point Amy how's that no
you can't do that if we there were four
in the back and then right we literally
can't even make them already no we we
got it that's too
easy all right all right all right all
right pull it together let's go finish
them come on guys I got kids at home
yeah
oh so close do you want to go first
please ladies lock it up yeah I know I
really also watch that elbow just
remember what happens to the losers you
guys watch that elbow hey
watch the bomb watch your mouth yeah
wow
trying to say Lena you'd have to drink
that [__] again in the final drink it
Lena so if so if Lena makes it now
there's no rebuttal right that's what it
is
way off I almost want to give you a
retry for that one
all right so do I get so someone drink
that one and then you guys get a chance
to rebuttal yeah
what's in the gamer girl bath tonic
again
that one is chocolate syrup aloe water
and goat cheese
and Greek and Greek
yogurt
and the Greek the Greek yogurt
oh okay
ah awesome guy he almost went behind the
wall which was kind of a move
think when people are suffering [__]
this what's behind their AB that you're
just looking for a little privacy when
you go back there just a moment moment
for yourself right
no no they won
so these guys get a chance to rebuttal
now oh okay yeah where are you taking a
couple with wait is this did they hit
twice no no no I pulled one okay got it
all right wait there's six cups there
that's what I was saying nobody won oh
no oh then go again Olivia oh okay but
wait there's a couple right I pulled
another cup that there was a drink in it
so wait okay I think there's a lot so
you girls are up by one cup yeah one
more you just guys just gotta hit this
you girls one cup in the same sentence
one cup
put them away
Olivia's right up in there so close all
right
five percent battery no definitely not
definitely very cool because I want you
to have so far away
sounds good yeah
maybe queuing up
right up the rim Zack
the way I think I'm magic is a little
bit embarrassing
oh man that Nails it now it's tied six
six
next Cup winner so if you make this one
after this you win if you make this you
win
yes wait okay
come on Zach sit just let me go home I
just want to go home bro
foreign
this one is Red Bull salt lime olives
and mini Martini onions delicious
dude I really wanna not bad
oh did you hit it you're done already
nice yeah
Dan I really want to check in on this uh
Jordan Peterson Sam Cedar argument looks
so interesting they're still arguing
yeah
we'll talk about tomorrow
one ball one win one God one love one
love
one planet
one star
one ring
to roll them all
this overhand count
yeah she can shoot out where she wants
all right baby we got this
can we get a rerack
yeah he's permitted now nice nice
on your turn yeah you can ask
your call is that good yeah
who was that
we're all counting on you Jack
[__] me I
was going to give you a retry you're
getting worse Zach you're getting worse
all right ladies come on
[Music]
dude re-rack it
Lena this is remember you're gonna have
to drink that [__] again in the final
sauce because it's all getting mixed up
is it supposed to be motivating yes I'm
saying sync it okay so you don't have to
drink that crap
oh my God that was so close
Olivia was right there
this is tense people it is six six
people are like these guys do not want
to lose
this is a tense tense game people our
GoPro is at two percent you guys gotta
wait they can see the battery yes yeah
You Gotta Sink it I don't know it's okay
it's okay all right our GoPro is about
to go out
everybody has to drink what is rebuttal
no the rebuttal is
um I guess you can keep the game going
so does that first you got to drink that
[__]
oh
do you want do you want to do it no
that's okay you sure yeah Lena wait I
already did this one do I did I wait
don't I get to shoot again do I have
here I think we've only done the iced
tea one once
I don't know wait I get to shoot again
oh well but you just no he went after
she eats it all right just just drink
still the thing is they still have cups
so the rules are a little weird because
usually when you win there's no cops
Lena who just got back from yakking is
Downing another one like a warrior
are you okay she's stomping her feet
like Happy Feet doing Taylor Swift says
some people say those are Happy Feet but
not today folks
foreign
which one was that
this was the Primal punch
this is really hitting Lena hard today
yeah it's beyond me horseradish fish
sticks spinach oatmeal that one sounds
really disgusting
but let's try the rebuttal really quick
all right y'all so glady's go ahead and
rebuttal if you hit it
it's first to uh Miss if you hit it I
guess yeah then you go to a showdown
okay
right
foreign
this is free come on
coming clutch
come on Elena I just can't think about
it you just have to go yeah
[Laughter]
oh all right we have an official loser
congratulations to the guys all right
unfortunately the ladies
played their hearts out but in the end
to the honors it just wasn't enough just
wasn't enough so let's uh oh Sam you
already did Sam is bringing out
the Blessed drink
this all ten all ten beverages mixed
together this is known as Heaven's Mana
I've already got a bomb let's give it a
sniff to describe it to us I can smell
it from here what does it smell like
like okay bad okay bad it smells like a
mixture of everything she doesn't like
it potato all right well
here we go
this one's for you Mom it smells so bad
you got this this one's to you Mom we
love you girl power
girl boss that drink
all girl bosses girl boss are down right
now Olivia
a pretty small stuff better than the
other one
it's like Loki sweet
try it okay I'd love to it's kind of
good huh kind of good Lena's excited
actually to try this uh there's
something yeah there's alcohol oh wait
there's alcohol in it is that okay
there's like a little bit of you can't
do it oh Shane Chef Cameron coming
through
mushroom let's get the mixture nine of
them you're not getting out of this
Nine without the alcohol one for Lena I
could take a second sip no but uh thank
you Kim
sorry
you stepped into the ring as a
competitor
right you got a little smile again
nice try
I didn't want to back out of it anyways
if Olivia did it you know
play beer pong at a party
it'd be pretty good you'd be pretty good
yeah you'd be pretty good
not bad
so they are uh creating the cocktail
there's some some gagging
going on back there with Dan and Sam
screams of desperation Dan had to walk
away some Bros
that bad because I think just like the
culmination of everything made just like
everything neutralize
all right
here we go chunkier
ugliest texture I think that one's kind
of stringy
this I've never seen him make the
stringy okay so now we have a
alcohol-free
version for Lena
who was not trying to get out of it
there we go oh that was a good sip
she's puckering
not too bad you said
it's sweet right I thought it'd be
better
well there it is I guess congratulations
or well done to the ladies
[Applause]
you guys
experienced The Impossible you took it
all the way thank you to Olivia and Lena
who in
um who in defeat showed Grace some honor
humility that's right
and they are our Champions today in a
way not really I am but in a way
and I want to thank Dan for making zero
shots on my team it was all me
you're welcome I just wanted to make you
shine by comparison thank you so much
trying to you know I didn't want to
embarrass you too for the first time
you're not bringing me down right
exactly
I want to congratulate uh
Ian and ab who
merely escaped out uh Ian and Abe a b
and Zach
whatever Lewis
live at the Roxy
Lily
May what but anyway did I think all
these guys did I think are Rochelle is
Canadian already gifted I think I did
right yeah thank you so much I want to
thank all of our wonderful audience out
here a four hour episode that's just how
we do it an hour of which was me
silently eating McDonald's yep
another hour of which was a silently uh
lining up our shots for beer pong and
this is what lots of Silence nobody does
what we do
a lot of dead air today and it's too bad
we're banned on all of our Tick Tock
accounts because I think that clip of me
eating would really do well there right
I have no job anymore
I'm gonna well yeah we need a
that's so [__] up
people of tick tock please Tick Tock is
our home
and I I do have to go but tomorrow
morning we're going to be here leftovers
with Hassan Hassan
the lovely
the small-headed
Hassan ABI small head but big brain big
heart and oh that's even better small
head but a big heart I guess he has a
thin skull if his brain is Big right
yeah exactly because his head is small
how do you fit a big brain well most of
your head's volume is taken up by like
your mouth and stuff but that's just all
brain matter for him just it just fills
up the whole volume Yep this man wants
most people most people bite their cheek
son actually went into uh
his lip
all right y'all see you tomorrow morning
and uh thank you and God bless oh we got
one last message Chicago accent is not a
Midwestern accent Sac midwesterners have
the funniest accident in America so much
so that newscasters learned from them
said Chrissy called you a liar Well
Chrissy wake up
I don't like this
oh if he's going to puke oh
Amy's going to puke potentially oh wow I
heard a disguise and then looked over
your baby he's over there with you yeah
I'm I'm not puking I'm just using the
bathroom
potentially a side of puke using the
bathroom with Potentials in the bathroom
how many people are
up there what he is no why was he okay
I think that ninja goo or whatever
well we had potentially two pukes today
so that's pretty good guys we'll see you
tomorrow morning uh thanks for watching
this is the H3 family
[Music]
foreign